[Musique]
Antoine Armand bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement je m'appelle Antoine Armand
j'ai 33 ans je suis député de haut de
savoir d'cy mon des lacs et des plaines
qui l'entourent depuis juin 2022 j'ai
été ministre de l'économie des finances
et de l'industrie de Michel Barnier
pendant un petit peu moins de 3 mois je
travaille depuis un moment sur les
sujets qui me passionnent l'industrie
l'énergie l'agriculture les finances
publiques évidemment et je me définirais
comme un libéral souverainiste
c'est-à-dire que je pense qu'il faut
être pro business à l'intérieur de nos
frontières mais savoir les défendre
bienvenue on est très content de vous
recevoir aujourd'hui parce que on rêve
de parler de finance d'agriculture de
géopolitique et de perspectiv pour la
France première question qui a un
running gag je suis désolé parce que
depuis les quatre interviews on l'a fait
combien il y a de zéro à 1 milliard il y
a 90 à 1 milliard et 800 milliards ça
fait combien d'épaisseur en lias de 50
€. plus compliqué alors 50 € x 2 100 €
non non non en épaisseur physique ah
pardon moi j'étais déjà en train
d'essayer de compter le nombre de
billets de 50 pas mal pas mal mais mais
je pense que c'est important j'en
profite pour rebondir sur cette question
c'est pas une boutade sur cette
question la matérialité du monde dans
lequel on vit la guerre la dévastation
de l'Ukraine le rapport de force
russo-américain avec l'Europe au milieu
est complètement réelle et elle se
transmet ou elle se transcrit dans le
débat par des choses qui n'ont aucune
réalité pour les gens 1 milliard
pourquoi est-ce que la plupart des gens
ne savent pas combien il y a de zéro
parce que ça n'a aucun sens et que le
cerveau humain est bloqué dans son dans
sa compréhension et dans sa capacité à
l'appréhender ça fait quelle distance en
lias de 50 € 800 milliards c'est vrai
que je connais pas les
dimensions bet d'après croc ça fait 1600
km d'accord pas mal pas mal bon on va
rentrer plus plus euh dans le détail de
la finance vous avez été 4 mois ministre
de de des finances françaises et de
l'industrie de l'économie et de
l'industrie comment ça se passe quand
vous arrivez on vous présente quoi comme
dossier vous avez trouvé les les
finances de la France dans quel état et
avec quelle
perspective alors petit point de de de
méthode qui est difficile à à à exprimer
qui a pas l'air important mais qui est
très important an j'étais en charge des
finances et j'avais un collègue en
charge du budget rattaché au Premier
ministre qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que j'avait un collègue
Laurent Saint-Martin qui élaborait le
budget qui regardait combien on allait
dépenser combien on gagnait et qui
reportait au Premier ministre pour faire
la trajectoire mais votre serviteur lui
il était chargé responsable de la
prévision de croissance d'inflation de
déficit de l'année suivante et chargé de
défendre ensuite la trajectoire globale
la trajectoire comme on dit pour les
prochaines années à Bruxelles et dans
les sommets internationaux et cette
diarchie je le dis très simplement je
pense qu'elle a été problématique parce
qu'évidemment il vaut mieux avoir une
intégrité c'est ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui avec mon successeur et avec
un grand ministère économie finances et
budget pour contrôler tout de l'AM à
laaval qu'est-ce qu'on vous
présente on est on vit dans un pays de
longue date et je le présenterai pas
d'abord comme une critique qui est un
pays administratif
euh dont l'unité de la nation la
souveraineté s'est constitué par
l'administration de il y a depuis il y a
1000 ans jusqu'à aujourd'hui et donc
pourquoi je fais ce détour ce qu'on vous
présente quand vous arrivez au ministère
c'est le travail et le périmètre de
chaque direction donc la direction en
charge de la politique économique vous
présente la politique économique la
direction en charge de la collecte des
impôts vous présente la collecte des
impôts la direction en charge des
entreprises vous propose les principaux
secteurs la question que vous posez
implicitement c'est quelle vision de la
France on vous propose et on ne vous
présente pas de vision globale
panoramique compréhensive pardon pour
l'anglicisme du pays c'est à vous de la
faire et ce que vous constatez ce que
j'ai constaté à ce
moment-là c'est qu'il y a une sorte de
de contraste en tout cas de de de
paradoxe qui est mine de rien très
violent la violence de ce paradoxe c'est
que vous avez
d'un côté une économie française qui est
euh vaste
solide différencié vous savez pourquoi
j'utilise ces mots ouais solide ça
m'intéresse beaucoup ces trois mots
c'est les mots qu'utilisent les agences
de notation et les Chinoises les celles
celles qu'on suit donc plutôt plutôt
américaine ou anglo-saxon et elle les
utilise comme des analystes
internationaux c'est-à-dire avec des
clients qui se fournissent auprès de ses
agences et qui donc veulent des mots qui
ont une percussions qui ont un sens
solide ça veut dire qu'on fait 1 % de
croissance depuis un certain nombre
d'années alors que d'autres pays on fait
zéro on fait 3 on fait un peu de
récession vaste c'est la géographie
c'est l'amplitude de l'économie et c'est
notre capacité à exporter et
différencier c'est parce qu'on fait du
tourisme industrie donc vous avez avec
toutes ces limites et je pense qu'on va
s'en reparler vous avez ça d'un côté et
de l'autre côté vous avez des finances
publiques qui sont j'aime pas ce terme
parce qu'il veut rien dire mais
structurellement problématique et
déficitaire qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
structurellement ça veut dire que euh ce
que vous la manière dont est construit
votre budget euh est déséquilibré je
peux je peux r oua oui bien sûr euh la
manière dont tu construitis le budget il
faut y
inclure les retraites promises depuis un
certain nombre d'années peut-être
certaines subordnations de vote donc
vote pour moi je suis le président du
pouvoir d'achat et j'ens pass des
meilleurs et le budget a été construit
là-dessus depuis combien de temps
ais j'ai j'ai dire quand j'étais
ministre que on n pas de budget
équilibré depuis
1974 on a depuis 1974 on n pas eu un
budget à l'équilibre premier choc
pétrolier c'était quelle année le
premier choc pétrolier c'était 1971
pardon c'était 20 ans avant ma naissance
vous avez l'âge du Christ oui mais pas
pour longtemps ah si j'espère enfin je
son âge est éternel contrairement au au
nôtre vous croyez en Dieu euh je suis
pas croyant et je réponds très rarement
à cette question mais je c'est bien anné
hein puisque vous faites la parenthèse
vous m'avz amené par les finances
publiques à la religion donc vous avez h
pourquoi c'est structurellement
déséquilibré et pourquoi depuis 50 ans
et pourquoi c'est problématique parce
que il y a plein de gens qui vous
expliquent très doctement que tout ça
c'est n'importe quoi que un la France
n'est pas une entreprise c'est vrai que
de la France n'est pas un foyer c'est
vrai et que donc c'est totalement
logique qu'on emprunte pour investir moi
je dis très bien d'accord mais pour
investir ce que veut dire investir c'est
que c'est rentable la dette
d'aujourd'hui c'est la dette qu'on
emprunte et qu'on rembourse en
l'occurrence on emprunte encore
puisqu'on rembourse que des intérêts
qu'on emprunte chaque année elle finance
pas les tableaux ou les iPads
d'après-demain pardon pour la marque les
tablettes numériques d'après-demain pour
que les enfants apprennent à s'en saisir
elles financent pas les universités d
dans 10 ans ou les dépenses militaires
elle finance les retraites des
fonctionnaires d'il y a 20 ans dans le
passé elle finance le fait que nos
dépenses de santé sont pas à l'équilibre
depuis 25 ans autrement dit si je fais
la comparaison vous êtes un ménage
aujourd'hui vous êtes à la tête de votre
foyer c'est unard de le présenter comme
ça pardon mais vous êtes à la tête de
votre foyer et chaque chaque chaque
année vous gagnez 100 et chaque année
vous dépensez 105 et les 5 de plus que
vous dépensez c'est votre emprunt à la
conso d' il y a 10 ans qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand on a une spirale de
surendettement ce qui se passe quand on
a une spirale de
surendettement il y a deux il y a deux
deux conséquences possibles et qui sont
de nature différentes pas de degré de
nature différente la première celle dans
laquelle on se trouve
aujourd'hui
c'est j'allais
dire le je cherche le boa constrictor
c'est-à-dire que Pon ridiculé oui alors
je suis très mauvais en serpent parce
que j'ai une phobie très forte de
l'animal
mais c'est-à-dire que le corps qui est
prix est de plus en plus faible et le
corps qui l'entoure est de plus en plus
fort et donc le coût de la dette
augmente ce que vous devez le terme est
très bon il date de de la Fondation des
étatsntion même avant d'ailleurs c'est
le service de la dette est de plus en
plus important et donc vous êtes asservi
financièrement à la dette alors c'est le
le le le l'ordre de grandeur qu'on donne
he aujourd'hui c'est 50 milliards
d'intérêts de la dette c'est à peu près
le niveau du budget de la défense
connaissez le proverbe pourra servir les
peuples et la dette allez-y non non je
vous écoute non il y a rien de mieux que
la dette pourra servir les peuples je le
résume trivialement ou voilà et donc ça
a un sens puisque comme vous pouvez plus
faire l'économie de servir la dette
sinon vous pouvez plus continuer votre
train de vie déséquilibré vous devez
faire des efforts directement sur les
gens là où se trouve l'argent et puis la
deuxième conséquence possible qui est
d'une nature différente parce que la
France n'est pas la Grèce en tout cas
pas aujourd'hui et et pas demain ou
après-demain c'est quand où vous avez
menti où il y a une différence radicale
entre ce que vous présentez de votre
économie de vos finan de votre industrie
et ce qu'on constate et donc là le
problème c'est que on ne vous fait plus
confiance du tout et là le problème
n'est plus le coût de la dette c'est qui
qui veut vous vous encore vous prêtez et
là vous sautez vous avez fini oui merci
pour cette introduction pour les les
béien de la finance on a la chance sur
sinkervview d'avoir une communauté qui
est rompue aux exercices de marché d'une
d'une du New York Stock Exchange et j'en
passe et des meilleurs on va rentrer
plus en détail on va parler guerre
économique parce que vous nous avez
tendu des perches concernant la guerre
économique avec les agences de notation
les fonds vautours les les les dettes
attaqué les dettes à au variable les
empreunes au varibles pardon je voudrais
qu'on rembobine un petit peu tout ça
avec votre arrivé et vos anticipations
vos prévisions comment on fait quand on
est ministre pour pouvoir faire une
prospective une anticipation on a accès
à du jus de cerveau de qualité au
ministère qui vous donne non pas des des
chiffres avec des lunettes rose pour
vous rassurer comment ça se passe
ce qui est très frappant c'est que alors
évidemment là c'était la caricature
puisque notre c'est ça notre espérance
de vie notre je sens qu'on y reviendra
notre espérance de vie notre espérance
de vie estimée quand on arrive avec le
gouvernement de Michel Barnier est très
faible elle s'est avéré faible et donc
plus que jamais le contraste entre
l'horizon de temps qu'il faut se donner
et l'horizon de temps auquel on
réfléchit est différent
concrètement vous mettez autour de la
table je l'ai fait j'ai mux autour de la
table ce que le pays compte de s tank
autorisé ou moins autorisé ça dit quoi
des sank autoriséement pardon c'est quoi
des Ting tank non autorisés c'est une
manière de dire queil y a les ceux qui
ont opignon sur rue qu'on qu'on voit
beaucoup qui sont dans les journaux et
puis des beaucoup plus petits instituts
parfois lancés par des étudiants parfois
lancés par des gens qui ont beaucoup de
de qualités intellectuelle mais qui sont
moins connu question c'est s quand que
vous avez fait venir à la table de de de
notre ministère Bercy vous avez fait
leur pédigré vous les avez criblé qui
les finance quelles sont leur idéologies
surtout qui les finance par où ça passe
parce que qui
paye
décide absolument alors le principe
c'est que oui vous ne faites venir
autour de la table quand vous êtes
ministre en tout cas c'est votre
responsabilité que des gens dont vous
pensez que ils n'ont pas des intérêt ou
contraire à la nation ou qui défendent
des points de vue dont vous avez pour
reprendre votre plus cribler les
financements et l'organisation mais dont
vous estimez que c'est suffisamment
transparent pour savoir à quoi vous en
tenir si vous voulez j'ai un si si je
réinterprète la question pour essayer de
de de me dire qu'on va dans le bon sens
mon problème c'est si quelqu'un me parle
d'un endroit que je n'ai pas saisi si
j'ai le S tank des grands patrons de
boîes qui font plus d'un milliard
d'euros que je sais que c'est le cas qui
vient me voir et qui m'en parleing du
MDF j'ai aucun alors là l'occurrence
l'organisation patronnale j'ai aucun
problème je sais qui c'est d'où il parle
et quelle est sa gouvernance le problème
et ça j'ai pas eu en tout cas moi j'ai
pas eu l'occasion de le faire parce que
par exemple pour mettre les pieds dans
le plat j'ai pas reçu d'ONG dont je ne
connaissais pas exactement les source de
financement on avait commencé à
l'aborder dans la commission d'enquête
on avait pas eu le temps sur l'énergie
mais parce que là vous vous mettez dans
une situation difficile il y a quelqu'un
qui vous dit je défends X mais en fait
je suis financé par Y et là il y a du
prix h
donc si je reprends le fil euh prévision
anticipation conr prévision anticipation
en fait il y a un consensus assez large
chez ces acteurs là mais chez tout le
monde pour dire que allez si je prends
l'échelle industrielle et je reviens à
la matérialité des choses parce qu'en
fait euh on est dans un monde ultra
financiarisé on est dans un monde
évidemment très connecté digitalisé le
terme est très impropre mais tout part
toujours de la matérialité euh des
terres rares matériaux critiques énergie
infrastructure tout est matériel et
ensuite il y a des déclinaisons donc
c'est quand même intéressant de se
projeter sur les cycles de vie
industriels qui sont ceux qui
donnent qui donne une différence
d'où ce cycle de vie et ce cycle de vie
là il peut pas être de moins de 10 ou 15
ans et là vous comprenez le contraste
qu'il y a entre les décisions que vous
avez à prendre c'est-à-dire le niveau
auquel vous fixez l'aide à France 2030
le programme d'investissement pour
l'année prochaine est-ce que vous vous
le fixez à 500 millions ou à 1 milliard
quelle est l'inertie en cours combien il
faudrait sur 10 ans et là oui vous vous
coincez à la réalité du court terme on
vous a repéré grâce à votre présidence
de la commission énergie rapport rapport
pardon vous avez bien bossé c'est pour
ça que on a vraiment insisté pour vous
faire
venir c'était bien mené et c'était de
très grande qualité on était content de
payer votre salaire
et votre clé de lecture votre clé de
voûte pour le futur c'est quoi votre
pierre angulaire qui comme un laser vous
permet d'anticiper ce qui se passe pour
la France quelle est votre clé de
lecture votre clé de
voûte
c'est je dirais
euh une clé c'est souvent enfin c'est
c'est un centre ou un barrycentre et
donc moi j'ai trois angles qui viennent
faire cette clé-là c'est la lucidité
euh et donc pardon le dire mais on a
toujours tendance à ne pas voir ce qui
est gênant ou ce qu'on ne veut pas voir
et donc moi le premier je l'ai eu je
l'ai eu et on va sans doute s reparler
sur l'énergie
euh parce que je suis persuadé et
persuadé est un mauvais mot parce que je
suis convaincu qu'on a besoin de plus
d'électricité demain et après-demain et
qu'il faut du nucléaires et des énergies
renouvelables j'ai eu moi-même la
difficulté à voir que certains soutiens
aux énergies renouvelabl ne sont ou pas
efficaces ou contradictoires avec des
politiques énergétiques donc lucidité
deè principe c'est les matières
premières mais vraiment je ne matières
premières et infrastructure je sais pas
à quel point il faut insister là-dessus
parce que au fond le
euh tout tout ce qui concourt
aujourd'hui à faire croire que la
digitalisation veut dire la
déréalisation ou la dématérialisation
est simplement un manque de
compréhension
de ce qui se passe je vous prends une
anecdote très concrète j'ai à N un
laboratoire qui s'appelle le lap
laboratoire d'accélération des
particules qui travaille en coopération
avec le cerne qui est à Genève je la
fait et vraiment je m'excuse auprès de
toute la physique mondiale pour ce que
je vais dire de résumer le cerne mais
qui vise à comprendre le comportement
des particules et qui vise à se
rapprocher en temporalité le plus
possible du moment du Big Bang bon
aspect scientifique non négligeable
on n pas assez de débit pour faire le
travail et quand on fait l'ordre de
quand on prend le l'ordre de ce qu'il
faut pour avoir les serveurs pour faire
tourner juste en haut de sa voie avec
notre industrie ce qu'il faudrait pour
l'économie et pour la recherche on voit
qu'on n'y est pas du tout et donc c'est
bien une question de matière d'espace de
foncier d'industrie et mon dernier point
je sais qu'il y en a que deux mais mon
dernier point c'est l'ordre de grandeur
alors ça je reconnais que dans ma propre
formation intellectuelle c'est ce sans
doute ce qui qui a été le plus inspiré
par Jean-Marc jankovici et par d'autres
c'est l'ordre de grandeur c'est-à-dire
que un n'est pas 1000 et donc quand un
panneau photovoltaïque a un facteur de
charge de en moyenne 10 à 15 % c'est ça
dépend quand
l'éolien sur terre c'est 10 à 16 10 à 20
% je prends une fourchette prudente
c'est quoi vos sources euh alors les
sources de ça c'est RTE réseau transport
d'électricité euh parfois aussi l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie mais les
comparaisons sont sont sont plus simples
avec RTE et 2uxème élément quand vous
prenez l'alléolien en mer vous pouvez
être de 20 à 40 % parce que plus vous
éloignez des côtes plus il y a ce qu'on
appelle du foisonnement c'està qu'il y a
toujours du vent et ben vous comprenez
que c'est pas la même chose qu'un
facteur de charge de 80 % EDF
euh du nucléaire et il y a un rapport de
1 à 8 si je prends photovoltaïque et
clair autre ordre de
grandeur ça c'est aussi alors il y a un
peu RTE un peu Adem euh le la quantité
de carbone qu'il est nécessaire pour
faire 1 kWh et ben vous voyez que pour
le nucléaire c'est moins que pour la
plupart des énergies renouvelable et ça
c'est le juge de paix c'est l'ordre de
grandeur est-ce que dans votre parti
politique ou au château ou à Matignon
ils sont câblés comme vous ah c'est
vraiment une question
infecte et mais je
sal je savais que vous prendrez ça comme
un
compliment c'est question parce que il y
a un cas on comprend pas inf dans on est
pragmatique mais il y a un cas où je
suis
prétentieux il a un cas il y a un cas où
je suis carrément dégueulasse
mais quel vous allez
choisir vraiment je voudrais pas faire
honneur à utation centriste mais je vais
tourner le truc dans l'autre sens et
détourner une citation bien connue en
France l'intelligence n'est pas n'est
pas l'obstacle notre problème n'est pas
qu'on manque de gens qui
comprennent notre problème n'est pas
qu'on manque de grandes écoles
d'université de gens qui dans les
différentes matières y compris à
l'avant-garde aujourd'hui ne comprennent
pas notre problème je vais le dire de
manière extrêmement crue et je l'ai vécu
comme ministre l'ai vécu comme député
c'est la question qu'on se pose tous qui
est de se dire mais mais mais diable
comment est-ce qu'on peut avoir mis
autant de gens connaisseurs et sachants
et intelligent dans la même pièce qui
sortent tous déçus tous reconnaissant
que oui c'est un pisalé c'est pas
exactement la décision qu'il fallait
prendre c'est pas le bon horizon et ben
moi il y a un mot que j'aime bien qui
définit certaines nations en ce moment
et c'est normal en fonction de leur
histoire c'est la force d'âme ce qui est
en train de nous manquer en ce moment et
peut-être que ce qu'on VI va nous aider
c'est de la force d'âme c'est de
s'arracher de nous-même de de s'arracher
de de l'habitude technique scientifique
bureaucratique administrative politique
médiatique bien sûr qui nous conduit à
ça je vais pas le dire ça je vais
transiger en fait il y a des choses sur
lesquelles on peut pas transiger il y a
des choses sur lesquelles on peut pas
accepter de perdre du temps on en
reparlera mais on était on parlait
d'énergie est-ce qu'on peut
accepter que on mette trois ou quatre ou
C ou SEP fois plus de temps que des pays
asiatiques à construire un réacteur
nucléaire moi on peut se faire une
réunion de 4hur avec des gens très
sachants qui vont nous dire pourquoi
malheureusement c'est normal qu'on
mettre 7 fois plus de temps et je pense
pas faire insulte ni à la physique ni à
la technique en disant que on devrait
faire dans l'autre sens savez
normalement quand on élabore le budget
c'est la justification au premiers euros
dépensé et ben pour ce type de de projet
ça devrait être pareil c'est la
justification à la première minute
utilisée ah bon on a besoin de 15 ans ah
bah expliquez-moi ce premier mois il
sert à quoi réunion technique
interministérielle pour définir les
contours de la future
organisation est-ce que est-ce que ça
existe en Chine est-ce que c'est
indispensable vous avez voyagé un petit
peu j'ai voyagé un petit peu vous voulez
que je vous dise vous j'ai voyagé B
est-ce que vous connaissez la Chine je
alors anecdote je j'avais prévu un long
voyage en Chine et je devais y aller à
l'été 2024 bon il s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé donc ça a été repoussé moi
j'ai passé j'ai fait une école qui a
changé de nom en trois lettres dont on
doit plus prononcer le nom qui est
Lena a pu prononcer le nom ben parce
qu'elle a été sortie bannie bon on a
changé on l'a appelé l'Institut national
du service public ce qui fait c'est très
courant en France que maintenant les
gens disent je fais l'INP vous savez les
n donc bon ça prend juste plus de temps
à dire mais c'est le même principe et
dans le cadre de ce cursus j'ai fait un
stage de 4 mois à Séoul en Corée du Sud
alors tout est intéressant mais je
retiens juste deux choses qui sont
intéressantes la
première c'est que vous êtes dans un
pays qui globalement n'est pas
absolument concentré sur la France pour
le dire gentiment c'est-à-dire que vous
êtes je crois qu'à l'époque c'était la
12e puissance mondiale ça doit être
resté à peu près dans ces
aul dans un pays qui euh a euh face à
lui euh face à elle face oui face à lui
la Corée du Nord avec une histoire très
compliquée donc question sécuritaire
majeure mais qui a un surdéveloppement
économique avec la moitié de ses
habitants qui vivent dans la métropole
de soul qui concentre presque 20
millions un peu plus de 20 millions
d'habitants je crois euh et euh qui donc
n'a pas de rapport et de lien direct
avec la France donc un ça vous décentre
complètement et deuxième chose ça fait
le lien avec ce que je vous disais avant
sur la minute la justification à la
première minute c'est un pays
extrêmement rapide c'est qu'ils font pas
des réunions de 4h je alors je crois que
bon la bureaucratie envahit tout le
monde mais en tout cas les temps
d'exécution ne sont pas comparables à
ceux de la France comment on dit merci
en coréen on dit Kamsa amnida comment on
dit bonjour et Agan ào alors comment on
dit je t'aime ah je sais pas ça mais
vous c'est parce que j'ai pas eu
l'occasion de le dire en coréen juste
toujours le dire en français absolument
merci en coréen Kamsa amnida ça veut
dire faire acte de
reconnaissance en Asie notamment en Asie
sudnest le le comme dans plein d'autres
culture le le remerciement n'est pas une
formule de politesse c'est une action
donc on on montre on fait acte d'une
reconnaissance c'est pas il s'agit pas
de dire merci bonjour Tout va bien j'ai
mon technicien qui ent m' prendre du
coréen revenons revenons à nos moutons
c'est quoi une fonction
exponentielle alors une fonction
alors il y a deux réponses à vre
question la définition plate la la
définition plate de la fonction
exponentielle c'est que c'est une
fonction mathématique qui permet de
convertir un nombre en un autre nombre
et que plus on avance dans l'abscisse
plus l'ordonnée est très importante
c'est pour ça que pardon je le fais dans
le bon sens une fonction exponentiel
c'est quoi et ça me permet de faire une
parenthèse on l'utilise toujours ou
quasiment toujours plus exactement dans
le débat public à tort en gros on veut
on l'utilise souvent pour dire y = X ou
Y = 3x pour dire que ça augmente très
vite mais pas du tout pour dire que ça
explose et ce qui est très intéressant
je sais pas si à ça que vous voulez
envenir c'est que on a le monde tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui et et qu'on est en
train de décrire de vivre et
d'appréhender de très loin avec la
question des données avec la multitude
ne peut s'appréhender souvent que par ce
type de fonction mathématique qui
résiste beaucoup à la compréhension
humaine on change de change de oui de
type de fonction vous êtes plutôt jeu de
Go ou jeu d'échec ah échec depuis
longtemps 1900 2000 ah j'aimerais bien
mais je joue pas du tout assez pour ça
et du coup je me réfugie dans le Blitz 5
minutes pas de temps incrémental
le gong tombe ça vous oblige de trouver
à trouver l'équilibre entre eux et c'est
pas mal avec notre comparaison avecre
ouverture préférée c'est quoi ouverture
préférée Gambi dam euh voilà Gambi dam
Ren force tout de suite oui C4 voilà
revenons à
l'économie Bruno Le Maire il vous a
laissé Bercy en mode lunette rose j'ai
caché j'ai fait de la dette à gogo pour
éviter que les les agences de notation
nous dégradent et que l'intérêt de la
dette explose où il a fait de la dette
avec l'aide d'Emmanuel Macron et de
l'Assemblée nationale et de nos
institutions pour
masqué comme un pansement sur une jambe
de bois pourquoi on s'est retrouvé avec
une commission des finances et pourquoi
on se retrouve avec un ancien ministre
des Finances questionné sur pourquoi il
y a autant de dettes bon c'est la
question ça c'est très
clair point 1
à ma connaissance et je le dis comme si
j'étais en commission ça commence mal
non mais point 1 à ma connaissance et je
le dit comme comme si comme je l'ai dit
d'ailleurs à la commission
d'enquête je n'ai aucun indice aucun
élément qui me laisse penser qu'il y a
eu une dissimulation ou que quelque
chose a été caché disclaimer ça veut pas
dire que c'est moins grave où ça veut
pas dire que la situation est moins
problématique mais je me méfie
d'ailleurs de ce discours qui
consisterait à dire que c'est dissimulé
comme si on nétait pas collectivement
responsableou comme si c'était pas
évident point 2 il y a deux
deux deux points principaux de ce que
j'ai pu voir et appréhender à Bery qui
explique les écarts très important enfin
pour le dire simplement on passe de 4,4
% à 6,1 % de déficit il y a un point qui
est commun à d'autres pays européens non
non on se compare pas au dernier de la
classe non non je vais vous allez voir
vraiment ça prend des secondes le
premier point c'est malheureusement
assez classique qui nous arrive souvent
c'est on s'est trompé au plusieurs fois
sur nos prévisions de croissance ça veut
dire deux moins plus que les autres pays
mais quand même ça veut dire deux choses
premièrement s'en doute qu'on a été
optimiste volontariste ça c'est le mot
pour dire que on a été on s'est engagé
fort sans être dans une situation de le
voir et la deuxième chose manifestement
et la deuxième chose
c'est et la deuxième chose pardon c'est
que ça s'est passé dans un contexte
trèsché bon ça c'est la partie j'allais
dire le ruban commun puis ensuite il y a
la partie
franco-française qui est que on a on n'a
pas eu ni sur les impôts ni sur les
dépenses de collectivité on n' pas eu du
tout ce qu'on
attendait si je prends la métaphore du
percepteur d'impôt romain il rentre
après son tour des provinces avec X % de
moins
sur la TVA y% de moins sur l'impôt sur
les sociétés et à la fin ça fait des
milliards je peux vous couper monsieur
le
ministre le percepteur Robin qui a son
Kaiser qui le pousse à aller chercher
les
impôts
acceptés quand il sort avec sa charrette
il se dit bon il y a eu des problèmes
dans les
récoltes il sent qu'il va moins
percevoir parce que les BL ont moins
donné parce queil a plus comme c'est un
bon percepteur il sent les choses il
voit le ciel il se dit la pluie il se
dit il y a eu des guerres il dit y a eu
des tensions il il y a les barbares qui
nous ont ennuyé et il tombe pas des nuus
quand il va chercher son impôt il est
obligé de taper un peu plus les gens
pour récupérer les bas
deines je vais pas dire qu'au ministère
sur les gens parce que c'est faux mais
comment on peut faire des prévisions
avec des lunettes roses quand on n'est
pas connecté avec son monde la guerre
c'était cousu de fil
blanc les gens après le covid c'était
cousu de fil blanc la guerre économique
c'était cousu de fil blanc pourquoi
notre percepteur général tombe des nuus
sur les rentrées de TVA quand vous voyez
le nombre de business qui coule de PME
en augmentation
x% comment on peut faire des budgets
sans être connecté avec la
réalité bon vous avez avec la métaphore
du percepteur totalement pointé votre
métaphore c'est vrai la vous avez
totalement pointé la faiblesse du
système tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui je prends deux
exemples premier exemple on on ne sait
alors ça dépend des impôts l'impôt sur
ses sociétés c'est pas la taxe sur
valeur ajoutée et CETA mais pour Simp
on ne sait on est dans un
monde où il nous semblerait assez
logique de pouvoir avoir une forme de
vision en temps réel un
flux vous avez parlé des indices comme
les défaillances d'entreprise mais mais
la conso en fait pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui la consommation pardon
pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
pourrait pas avoir le flux quotidien TVA
ce que j'ai constaté par exemple c'est
que on n pas de suivi day today on a pas
de suivi aès jour après jour ou en flux
continu des dépenses vous rendez compte
on a 3300 milliards de dettes on a la
dépense publique la plus élevée de
l'Union européenne 58 % 57 58 % c'est le
record
pourcentage en gros on a le consensus
aujourd'hui des acteurs économiques
c'est que c'est c'est 8 à 10 points de
dépenses publiqu supplémentaire par
rapport aux autres pays et ce qui nous
différencie ce qui nous isole c'est la
dépense sociale et d'assurance maladie
quand vous comparez le reste c'est pas
c'est le même ordre de grandeur euh donc
premier point le flux continue on ne le
maîtrise pas on ne connaît pas donc ça
c'est est-ce que le percepteur il tourne
sans cesse dans toutes les provinces en
fait non il va de temps en temps tous
les trois ou 4 mois dans une province et
il il il voit ce qui il voit ce qu'il
voit il y a une superbe métaphore euh
que j'ai lu récemment et je ne sais plus
d'où je suis navré mais qui dit les
routes nous ont coupé du monde parce que
euh les grandes routes nous ont cé coupé
du monde parce qu'avant on devait
traverser tout un pays pour arriver
quelque part on voyait sa diversité
maintenant on n'arrive qu'au point final
bah c'est un peu ça on a le résultat et
le deuxième point euh donc premier point
le flux continu et le deuxième point
c'est les capteurs c'est les connecteurs
oui vous avez raison aujourd'hui
l'administration française n'est pas moi
j'ai lancé un comité scientifique en
juste après mon arrivée des
scientifiques indépendant académique je
leur ai dit vous travaillez 3 mois ils
viennent de rendre leurs travaux là puis
vous nous dites ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut améliorer et ben typiquement
l'administration française pendant des
années n'a pas regardé les les les
résultats économiques par secteur n'a
pas appelé les boîtes de temps en temps
formellement ou informellement pour
savoir où ça en était donc oui il y a
une question de connexion au monde qui a
joué très fortement dans les prêves le
d'expérience personnelle le percepteur
local qui m'envoie un mail le dimanche
du MO que je découvre son mail dimanche
soir il connaît parfaitement son
territoire il a même fait un cours à mon
expert
comptable vous avez pas des des des
connexions directes avec les gens de
terrain euh pas assez pour le dire très
simplement et pour développer euh vous
savez j'ai comment on a commencé cette
entretien je en disant finalement la
vision globale vous devez vous la faire
parce qu'on vous présente et c'est
normal d'un certain côté c'est vous
allez pas le reprocheter aux direction
le travail par périmètre administratif
et ben là on est tout à fait au cœur du
problème c'estàdire que le percepteur
dont on parle dans la vraie vie il est
rattaché à la Direction générale des
finances publiques mais le euh l'agent
administratif ou l'inspecteur qui est en
haute de sa voix à ansy et qui est
chargé de la région de SaintFélix Alb
surchérant et quintal il est pas au
téléphone où il fait pas une réunion
tous les 15 jours ou 3 semaines avec le
directeur économique d'auvern ronalp et
il fait pas une réunion de temps en
temps ou à une vingtaine en on pourrait
imaginer ça un échantillon avec le
ministre de l'économie pour dire bah en
ce moment les pressings vont très mal
c'est c'est un vrai exemple que je vous
donne que j'ai eu quand j'étais député
pourquoi parce que il y a un moment vous
avez eu difficulté de recrutement prix
de l'énergie et pouvoir d'achat en berne
donc vous reniez sur des dépenses comme
cellees-ci et vous aviez en France
partout des pressings qui s'atrophiaent
c'est la réalité dont vous parlez qu'
nous faut mieux appréhender non en tous
les cas on passe le bonjour à tous les
percepteurs qu'on a rencontré et
et bureau des impôts des entreprises à
chaque fois on est tombé sur des gens
super sympas super cool super pédagogue
et et surtout dans la motivation d'aider
et
et la classe depuis depuis plus de 12
ans on est tombé sur deux personnes
extraordinaires parenthèse fermée
revenons à l'anticipation les
prévisions la guerre le prix de
l'énergie quand on a un budget quand on
doit monter un budget si énorme on a
forcément des sondes en guerre
économique en renseignement en
contreespionnage en
contreingérence est-ce que vous quand
vous êtes quand vous avez été bombardé
ministre des
Finances il y a un responsable en guerre
économique qui est venu vous voir en
disant attention il y a ce pays-là ils
sont très très bélicux avec nos
entreprises on a des sones sur le
terrain ils vont nous ennuyer ou par
exemple cette entreprise française qui a
des ports un peu partout en Afrique qui
est en train de se faire vendre à gauche
à droite c'est problématique attention
cette entreprise là c'est dangereux pour
notre défense vous voyez à qui je peux
pas à qui je fais allusion et est-ce que
quand vous êtes rentré quand vous êtes
rentré ministre on a du jus de cerveau
spécialisé en guerre économique en
renseignement est-ce qu'ils sont venus
dans votre bureau en disant voilà les
information de première main de terrain
c'est ça ça ça ça vous aidera à faire
votre budget euh
oui avec deux ou trois
limites non
négligeable la première c'est que
notamment sur ces sujetsl il y a une
certaine diarchie entre le ministère des
armées et le ministère de l'Économie et
que on est dans un monde où et c'est pas
une critique mais les militaires
considèrent qu'ils ont des prérogatives
et un domaine dans lesquels il est pas
question que
l'économique s'installe et donc il y a
de l'intelligence économique et de la
guerre économique qui se fait au
ministère des arméesans s Mercy
l'inverse n'est pas tout à fait vrai la
deuxième limite c'est que c'est aussi le
domaine réservé du président de la
République et
que des choses pour lesquelles vous êtes
tenus au courant d'autres non et puis
des choses sur lesquelles vous avez pas
le levier d'action et la troisième
limite qui est la plus grave peut-être
enfin la plus gênante
peut-être c'est
que j'ai je l'ai vu je le vois depuis
dizaine d'années parce que dans ma
formation j'ai j'ai l'occasion de faire
un passage au ministère des Affaires
étrangères à Paris au siège et et où
j'ai pu voir se mettre en place qu'on
appelait à l'époque qu'on appelle
toujours eu oh là alors euh oh là là
c'est dur ça parce que j'ai un doute sur
l'année
euh je pense que c'était en
2000 ah je vais vraiment vous je pense
que c'était en 2014 il ressemblait à
quoi ah mais je l'ai pas vu moi j'étais
un simpleagère dans l'administration à
la direction européenne non non non je
c'est pour d'ailleurs c'est intéressant
vous avez pas du tout bon don je je vous
désolé je pense que c'était en 2014 mais
j'ai un doute euh je pense que c'était
en
2014 quels étaient les faits marquants
de 2014 alors les faits marquant de 2014
TER de politique étrangère et de
souousbressau internationaux alors les
fait de 2014 il y avait alors sur ma
partie en tout cas le recovery la le le
le comment dirais-je la rémission de la
crise économique et financière et la
grande difficulté avec l'Allemagne de
retrouver un une forme de chemin
économique
dual ça c'était pour la partie que moi
j'avais en charge et on a été évidemment
débordé à ce moment-là par par la
question ukrainienne mais mais je l'ai
vu comment dirais-je en fait je l'ai vu
de l'extérieur
euh en fait je je l'ai vu de l'extérieur
et je pense comme beaucoup surtout
rétrospectivement euh on on l'a vu
comme on l'a vu comme un épisode c'est
un peu égalien mais on l'a vu comme un
épisode et pas comme un événement
c'est-à-dire que l'événement c'est
quelque chose qui euh porte en soi un
signal de l'histoire qui avance quelque
part qui s'inscrit dans quelque chose de
plus long qui était une tendance très
lourde et moi mais comme plein d'autres
on l'a vu évidemment comme un épisode
aussi inquiétant et dramatique soit-il
et on aurait dû s'inquiéter de ne pas le
comprendre parce que quand vous
comprenez pas quelque chose qui se passe
c'est sans doute qu'il a il a en gererme
quelque chose de beaucoup plus profond
c'est pour ça qu'on a pas vu la guerre
avec les Russes débarquer parce que tout
le monde a pensé que c'était juste un
épisode parce qu'on avait pas les bons
capteurs depuis 2014 parce qu'on a pas
écoué ce qui se passait à gauche et à
droite qu' y avait personne sur le
terrain pour faire une remontée une
remontée d'information brute à nos
ministres à notre président à nos
présidents j'aimerais vous répondre mais
d'abord j'en suis pas capable parce que
j'ai pas du tout les éléments pour le
dire mais je je constate vraiment qu'on
a été très si à mon niveau d'élu ou de
juste avant d'être élu personne qui
travaillent au ministère des Finances
qui s'intéressait à la politique j'ai eu
le sentiment de le découvrir ou le
comprendre c'est qu'on a collectivement
manqué les clés de compréhension et je
reviens juste à mon point d'avant euh
c'est du 2014 parmi les choses moins
importantes et très administratives le
moment où se déroulait la question de la
diplomatie économique et
euh si on fait un tout petit peu
d'autocritique c'est jamais grave le
souvent très productif le le la le
concept même posait problème
c'est-à-dire que le ministère des
Affaires étrangères s'est doté comme
d'une nouvelle comme d'un nouveau bras
de la diplomatie économique sous-entendu
ou une nouvelle branche du soft power ou
une nouvelle manière de faire du positif
et donc si je reprends le fil de votre
question en disant est-ce qu'on est venu
vous voir la manière d'appréhender n'est
ni le défensif ni l'offensif c'est le
partenariat et maintenant qu'on vit dans
un monde qui est manifestement
antiartenarial à beaucoup d'égards on se
rend compte de l'inadéquation de nos
outils mais c'est totalement logique
quand vous avez une analyse vous
déployez un outil et quand votre analyse
est fausse ou incorrecte votre outil est
rarement adapté et l'outil ne me paraît
pas très adapté vous avez déjà essayé de
faire un trou dans le mur avec un coton
tige non et avec un forêt avec une tête
en carbure de tangsten alors je ne sais
pas si c'était du carbure de tangsten
mais j'ai déjà essayé de faire un trou
avec un forê oui dans le renseignement
économique vous pensez qu'on a des
cotonstiges ou des forês ou carbures de
ttinsten c'est une vraie question
difficile parce que j'ai eu le sentiment
qu'on avait des forêts en Carbur de
tangsten à beaucoup de à beaucoup de
moments je ne peux pas aussi dire que
j'ai été destinataire de toutes les
informations quel est votre point de
comparaison c'est-à-dire
bah je prends mon ami qui habite à à
villeen de famalikang ouais qui est
portugais qui m'a appris t des des
forêts au Carbur de tangsten quand il y
a un Français qui vient me voir et qui
montre un forê je lui dis ça c'est pas
un forêt pour faire du béton donc quel
est votre point de comparaison pour
savoir reconnaître identifier un fin
ligé c'est une question
difficile
c'est je dirais deux choses
premièrement l'information dans son
contexte l'administration française et
le renseignement et l'intelligence
économique n'y échappe pas
et fonctionne par
note bon qu'est-ce que ça veut dire une
note ça veut dire que c'est souvent une
information quelle couleur
la note
ça dépend alors c'est vraiment il y a on
peut vous faire le calidoscope des notes
elle elle est quand même souvent sur
fond blanc mais chacun met son logo bon
les bleus ou les
blancs
et et donc dans la note vous avez
souvent et ça c'est un défaut mais
classique vous avez souvent
l'information brute je vous fais je vous
donne un exemple faux fictif pour ne pas
mettre les gens en difficult donc le
pays du Wakanda voilà arrive sur votre
bureau un jeudi matin donc vous avezf un
mercredi vous mercredi midi vous partez
aux questions au gouvernement à
l'Assemblée national et au Sénat on va
vous interroger sur une papetterie dans
le nord de la France qui est en train de
fermer et vous êtes pas absolument sûr
d'avoir le bon élément donc vous
regardez avec vos services parce que il
est pas question de pas répondre
correctement un parlementaire quand vous
essayez de faire votre travail et juste
avant de partir dans le dossier qu'on
vous donne qu'on vous met dans votre
voiture sur le chemin on vous donne une
note
des
services sur
l'entreprise d'un pays important d'Asie
qui s'intéresse à un intérêt
potentiellement stratégique au
Wakanda parce que il a pris il a fait un
rendez-vous il a pris un contact deux ou
tro semaines avant vous avez cette note
vous avez plusieurs options la lire ou
pas euh demander un suivi un rendez-vous
sur ce sujet
euh et puis après charge à vous et à
votre cabinet de faire le suivi
ensuite peut-être que il se passe autre
chose mais qu'on vous remet pas la note
et puis vous pouvez pas faire un
rendez-vous sur chacun de ces thèmes
donc quand je parlais de vision je pense
que là où on peut s'améliorer
collectivement c'est qu'il nous faut
géographiquement par périmètre par type
d'industrie faire ce travaill là de
terrains de
terrains je vous laisse récupérer
je vous en prie merci d'ailleurs c'est
ce que vous êtes pas à 100 % mais vous
êtes quand même là c'est bien revenons à
la prospective l'anticipation et
maintenant la
projection quand le ministre des
Finances voit que ça commence à pédaler
dans la smoule il fait quoi il appelle
son copain au château il appelle son
copain à Matignon il fait comment est-ce
que vous pouvez préciser pédaler dans la
semoule bah quand des budgets dérapent
quand il y a x fond souverain qui est en
train d'attaquer notre dette ou quand il
y a x nation qui commence à être
agressive il y a il y a un conseil des
ministres comment ça se passe alors le
le je prends le premier la première
proposition d'exemple fait qui qui est
pratique parce qu'elle est explicable
comme
ça début ou
mi-novembre on a une alerte sur le
déficit qui pourrait être encore plus
important que prévu alors qu'on est à la
toute fin de gestion et qu'on a déjà on
en a parlé eu un dérapage très important
avec mon collègue du budget on se
retrouve on met sur la table les
différentes options qu'est-ce qu'on peut
encore contrôler comme dépense d'IFI la
fin de l'année est-ce qu'il faut faire
une clause de régulation plus importante
pour cette année est-ce qu'on peut
décaler une partie de la dépense sur
2025 et on va porter ça tous les deux au
Premier ministre pour lui indiquer
l'éventail des solutions et là vous avez
la clé de voûe de la France le langage
techno appelle ça une rime c'est une
réunion
interministérielle c'est la décision de
la rime c'est ça se dit c'est rimé c'est
bleu ça revient chez vous et c'est la
preuve que
l'onction a été donné et quand revenir
dessus est difficile là je vous ai fait
le circuit court c'est celui où c'est
directement au niveau des ministres vous
avez le circuit qui se fait au niveau
des cabinets et où vous recevez une
décision qui a été prise en présence de
votre cabinet mais par quelqu'un du
cabinet du premier ministre avec
laquelle vous vous êtes foncièrement en
désaccord ou qui vous paraît pas
suffisante et c'est ce circuit là qui
quand il est court parce que il y a du
pédalage dans la semoule ou qu' a une
difficulté qui devient problématique
parce que
euh moiême je suis fonctionnaire com
vous gagnez alors comme député je gagne
5600 5650 € net 5700 € net je gagnais ce
salaire là quand j'étais à ber avant
d'être avant d'être député et comme
ministre je gagnais 10000 je je touchais
10700 € brut par mois
oui donc je suis fonctionnaire donc je
je fais pas de fonctionnaire bashing
c'est jamais une question individuelle
ça n'a aucun sens 95 % des
fonctionnaires son défonce bien sûr non
mais de toute façon on s'enferme dans ce
sujetl c'estàdire que si par exemple je
vous dis il y a un nombre trop important
d'agents publics en France est-ce que
c'est du fonctionnaire bashing non c'est
c'est c'est ridicule de se laisser
enfermer dans ce débat là est-ce que
pour dire qu'il y a trop de
fonctionnaires en France par rapport à
d'autres pays et qu'il faut réduire la
taille de l'état de ce qu'on appelle
parfois le Deep state il faut faire des
efforts quoi le Deep state ce qu'on
appelle le Deep
state c'est alors c'est une formule
importée qui se prête assez
mal à la France qui porter de mémoire
des États-Unis c'est-à-dire que c'est un
peu l'idée de les élites administratives
versus le politique c'estàdire que les
politiques passent mais les
fonctionnaires administratifs restent
oui et ce qui est une vérité la question
c'est est-ce que l'administration est
loyale au politique moi je n'ai jamais
expérimenté le contraire
l'administration sous ma direction n'a
jamais fait le contraire de ce que j'ai
demandé défon pour la France bien sûr
maintenant est-ce que parce que les
administrations ont une longéité bien
plus importante et les services bien
plus importantes est-ce que il y a une
forme de doctrine qui s'élabore et qui
finit par être diffusé auprès du
ministre évidemment vous vous parliez
tout à l'heure des dossiers qu'on
présente si je vous dis que en 3 mois
j'ai traité tous les sujets de tous les
secteurs et que je me suis fait mon avis
sur tout je vais avoir l'air d'un
Charlot et vous aurez bien raison de me
dire vous êtes bien gentil circulez mais
il y a rien à voir donc qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que dans votre
dans votre panier ministériel surtout à
l'automne 2024 parmi les secteurs qui
sont tout à haut de votre pile vous avez
l'automobile avec la situation des
amendes vous avez l'aéronautique parce
que parenthèse le trafic aérien expose
dans le monde entier mais on fragilise
nos compagnies et nos constructeurs
européens et notamment français et vous
avez j'allais dire l'industrie lourde
parce que la Commission européenne s'est
assez peu intéressée à l'industrie
lourde et donc si des
chimie et cetera et la défense
évidemment mais vous avez peut-être pas
mais à coup je vais je vais prendre le
risque de donner un ou deux secteurs
vous avez peut-être pas en première
ligne ce qui reste de textile français
ligne y compris des choses plus
importantes même la production d'un Tran
vous savez la production d'un TR mais
elle
est faiblesse telle que
vous avez peut-être pas sur ces
sujets-là mis votre poids politique ou
mis du temps pour faire une nouvelle
doctrine et dans ce cas-là qu'est-ce qui
se passe bah c'est l'administration qui
gère et est-ce qu'il peut y avoir une
autre
solution je sais pas en ayant plus de
monde dans les cabinets ministériels en
éloignant le ministre du quotidien c'est
difficile à dire et s'il y a quelque
chose qui ressemble au deep state c'est
ça c'est le fait que face à l'actualité
qui vous déborde à la
surmédiatisation sur beaucoup de sujets
monsieur le ministre monsieur le député
on vous a suivi de très près
sur l'énergie on vous a suivi de très
près à votre arrivée à
Bery vous êtes bien câblé concernant
l'énergie vous avez totalement compris
comment fonctionnait l'économie comment
vous expliquez qu'Emmanuel Macron a
voulu fermer 12 réacteurs nucléaires
il y a alors c'est une longue histoire
il y
a je pense que
le le cadre conceptuel qui a présidé à
tout ça
euh c'est un peu le même que les 35 heur
si vous passz
expression c'est politique les 35 heur
c'était l'idée c'était c'était un le
travail est un gâteau et donc il suffit
de se partager le gâteau et il y aura
plus d'emploi on a eu la même vision
statique de l'électricité et de
l'énergie on s'est dit la sobriété
suffira à réduire notre
consommation donc
réduisons ce qui fait une grande partie
de la production électrique le nucléaire
et on l'a fait avec un contexte
politique qui est évident que vous vous
que vous rappelez que tout le monde se
rappelle et que je redis en un mot qui
est que à un moment il faut réunir des
personnalités qui vont d'Édouard
Philippe à Nicolas HULLOT bon
et cette question des 12 réacteurs et
puis moi je mets moi-même les pieds dans
le plat que vous allez me présenter si
je le fais pas et vous aurez raison il y
a la dimension du symbole qui est
incarné par-dessus tout par la centrale
de
fenheim parfaitement entretenu par les
deux réacteurs qui manquaent d'entretien
dont le niveau de sûreté était jugé
satisfaisant par laasn à la dernière
évaluation qui manquait dans entretien
mais dont le manque d'entretien n'était
pas ça je l'ai écrit noir sur blanc dans
le rapport on l'a écrit avec le
président Raphael chenberger partagé
écouter donc c'est du fait j'ai aucune
difficulté avec ça dont le manque
d'entretien n'était pas rédiibitoire
pour la poursuite de son
fonctionnement qui mérite quand même
d'être souligné dans un monde où aux
États-Unis les autorités de sûreté
pensent maintenant à des durées de vie
de 80 ans pour les réacteurs là où
faenheim approchait des 40 donc pour la
cuve pour la voilà en gros euh dans une
centrale dans un réacteur nucléaire sous
le contrôle des spécialistes qui me
corrigeront c'est pas exact vous pouvez
à peu près tout changer sauf la cuve euh
et euh la la longévité de la cuve n'est
aujourd'hui pas un enjeu jusqu'à 60
voire 80 ans les États-Unis euh
travaillent là-dessus et on est
d'ailleurs très content que les
États-Unis travaillent là-dessus parce
qu'ils vont nous même si c'est pas le
même design ils vont nous faire un gain
de temps euh assez considérable en la
matière donc il y a eu du symbolique il
y a eu du politique la fermeture de
fessonheim n'était pas une
fatalité peux pas vous dire plus que ça
je crois quand on voit que le monde
entier souhaite passer à l'énergie
nucléaire les Italiens sont en train de
s'activer fort fort d'autres puissances
on en est où en terme de prospective de
disponibilité de
l'uranium je vois où c'est les sourcils
non mais en fait je reprends à la
discussion qu'on avait un peu plusutôt
euh sur euh ou non non là ici la
question de la matérialité euh euh on
aborde le sujet de l'uranium souvent et
d'ailleurs on voit qu'on manque encore
d'information j'allais dire grand public
même s'il faut faire la part des choses
entre ce qui peut être dit ou pas on
voit que c'est typiquement un débat
comme souvent sur le nucléaire euh qui
est ou accaparé par les antis pour
trouver un argument de dire il faut
arrêter l'enfire ou qui a un circulé il
a rien à voir parce qu'on est pro
nucléaire donc surtout n'en parlons pas
sur la disponibilité du de l'uranium moi
je dirais deux trucs la première chose
c'est il faut pas avoir peur de faire la
photo la photo c'est si aujourdh vu le
nombre de réacteurs aujourd'hui en
fonctionnement dans le monde en a
combien il me semble que on est entre
200 et 300 je dirais 400 non ah
peut-être je j'aurais dit 443 ah bon ben
vous meilleur que moi alors 443 je me
prétends pas meilleur que vous enfin en
tout cas sur ce point
à vu de nez peut-être 450 et des
poussières ok j'aurais je très bien en
tout cas on partage en fonctionnement en
fonctionnement partage le Dee
eu et je n'ai pas 417 bravo et je n'ai
pas le le nombre mais en revanche je
pense que j'ai l'ordre de
grandeur le prévisionnel en construction
ou en prospective c'est c'est au moins
50 % de ça voire 100 % de ça donc je
commence par mon statique la photo tel
qu'elle est aujourd'hui montre ça c'est
les chiffres de l'agence
internationaleénergie atomique que on a
50 60 70 80 ans de réserve bon
d'uranium tel qu'on le
connaît c'est disponible pour mettre
dans des crayons et charger les
réacteurs absolument
eu c'est encore dans le sol encore dans
le sol ça c'est dans quel pays alors
dans les pays que on connaît enfin en
tout cas gen qui viennent de nous livrer
là alors non mais Australie Canada
Kazakhstan euh Nigéria bon Russie
Russie
Mongolie ça c'est la photo et puis il y
a le dynamique le dynamique c'est que si
les chinois construisent des réacteurs à
la vitesse à laquelle ils construisent
et que il faut prendre au sérieux ce que
dit l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
cette fois pas que atomique que les les
pays partagent l'idée de tripler la
capacité nucléaire dans le monde et ben
cette cette durée de 80 ans dont on se
parle elle peut très vite très très vite
changer de d'ordre de grandeur or dans
ce cas-là si on continue à penser que le
nucléaire est une solution ou qu'elle
mérite d'être expertisé il faut changer
de technologie ou faire évoluer la
technologie alors il y a l'option du
recyclage du multirecyclage je la fais
très courte mais vous récupérez une
partie de votre combustible usager vous
le traitez c'est ce qu'on est quasiment
les seuls à faire au monde à la Hague en
France et vous le réutilisez box MOX ça
ça coûte ça ça prend du temps de
l'énergie et on réutilise pas tout parce
que pour la faire simplement on sait
faire un un peu plutonium
euh oui alors pas dans pas dans le sauf
erreur pas dans le MOX qu'on utilise
dans nos réacteurs actuels c'est pour
les autres et donc vous faites un tour
puis vous essayez de faire un deuxième
tour de recyclage et là ça commence à
devenir très compliqué parce que pour la
faire simplement c'est comme comme
réutiliser un déchet plus vous le
réutilisez plus il vraiment sale et plus
c'est difficile de l'utiliser bon et
puis il y a la 4è génération qui est
l'idée de la réutiliser et réutiliser en
cycle
fermé la matière première neutron rapide
neutron rapide en gros qui vous permet
de de comment dirais-je de de de frapper
plus fort pour le dire très mal et donc
d'avoir une capacité d'avoir un
carburant un combustible beaucoup moins
facile beaucoup moins abordable que vous
pouvez réutiliser et là vous ouvrez une
autre perspective simplement ce timing
là pour l'obtenir il
est il y a beaucoup de débat on l'avait
commencé à lancer avec Astrit on a la on
a la science on a la techno on a le
savoir-faire mais c'est autre chose
d'avoir un réacteur fonctionnel euh euh
en la matière tout de suite mais si on
est en train de se dire que c'est 10 20
ou 30 ans pour l'avoir et que je
reprends mon raisonnement de dire tout
le monde fait du nucléaire et donc on a
peut-être plus 80 ans de réserve mais 60
50 40 tout d'un coup ça devient urgent
d'où l'ambition que je qu'on a porté
dans le rapport de relancer au plus vite
cette technologie- là de matière
industrielle en 2019 alors on n'a pas
fermé Astrid pour être tout à fait exact
on a arrêté le projet Astrid qui devait
mener à la construction d'un réacteur et
ça moi enfin d'autres l'ont déploré
avant moi mais je pense qu'il faut le
déplorer encore aujourd'hui parce que à
nouveau c'était pas 0 ou 1 on pouvait
faire un plus petit Astrid on pouvait
geler et attendre un petit peu et faire
un Astrid Hibernatus et 10 ans après au
moment où c'était plus adéquat de
ressortir là ça les compétences se sont
un peu éparpillées on laetrouve on les
retrouve dans les start-ups du nucléaire
qui existent aujourd'hui mais ces
start-up du nucléaire innovant elles
sont forcément pas la même force de
frappe que 600 ingénieurs au
CEA quand on entend dire que le secteur
du nucléaire a besoin de 100000
personnes toute profession confondue
d'ici
2030 ça fait combien de personnes engagé
par
jour alors 100000 personnes sous 5 ans
c'est ça donc bon allez 150000 vous me
l'accordez 150000 personnes sur 150 sur
sur combien 5 x 3500 jours vous voyez
vous avez le résultat
donc alors juste un point avant le
nucléaire c'est 220000 emplois direct
direct en France c'est
c'est moi quand j'en discute avec les
gens je vois qu'on a un peu une
perception de une centrale c'est les
Simpsons c'est-à-dire que vous voyez
dans les Simpsons il y a personne et
puis vous avez en gros vous avez
monsieur Burns dans son bureau qui de
temps en temps appuie sur le sur le
bouton il y a beaucoup de monde dans une
centrale et ils sont d'ailleurs très
très bien on les félicite parce qu'ils
ont géré la crise covid mieux que tout
le monde un ils ont géré la crise covid
mieux que tout le monde deux ils ont
fait face
à ce qu'on a appelait la corrosion sous
contrainte ils l'ont réparé dans des
délais énormes et
tr vous avez en tête beaucoup d'incident
nucléaire de niveau 3 4 5 en France ceux
qui sont annoncés ou même pas annoncé
non on a une une capacité de sûreté qui
est colossale donc oui combien de temps
il faut pour former un soudeur dans le
nucléaire alors on me l'a expliqué j'ai
peur de dire une bêtis mais en tout cas
c'est pas 3 mois ça la fout pas mal
qu'on soit obligé de venir des
Américains pour apprendre à souder en
France alors il y a plusieurs choses il
y a si vous pensez alors il y a
plusieurs choses parce que il y a le le
parc existant et puis il a il y a le
père de flamandville on a fait venir à
flamandville me semble-t-il des
Américains parce que c'était un design
technologie qui maîtrisait mieux que
nous de même qu'on envoie des des
Français en revanche oui on a un
problème de main d'œuvre on a on a plus
un problème de volume que de qualité de
main d'œuvre aujourd'hui alors cause
numéro
dégradation deenseignement de l'image de
l'enseignement professionnel et
technologique qui fait que c'est des
métiers qui attirent peu mais de
évidemment enfin en tout cas tout le
monde dans la filière vous le
dira manque de perspective qui a
provoqué évidemment un éloignement ou un
changement de métier quelle est votre
lecture du fait que l'Europe a repoussé
sa sortie progressive du gaz russe et
comment quel est votre regard sur le
fait qu'aujourd'hui on reçoit encore des
livraisons de d'uranium de Ros atome
dans nos ports
alors je commence par le deuxème et puis
je reviens en premier parce que le bon
sur la question de sur la question des
livraison sur la question plutôt sur le
fait qu'on continue à honorer nos
contrats avec Rosatom sur
l'uranium de retraitement c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait il y a que Ros atomes qui
dans le monde c'est faire ça du
combustible usager qui est retraité et
qu'on réutilise on n a pas absolument
besoin en
volume la compréhension que j'ai mais
honnêtement il faudrait demander à EDF
la compréhension que j'ai c'est que si
ça se fait avec
l'aval des autorités françaises ou en
tout cas sans l'interdiction des
autorités française et que DF continue à
le faire de mémoire ça représente 10 à
15 % des volumes utilisés
aujourd'hui il y a aussi une dimension
diplomatique de non rupture totale des
relations dans un domaine stratégique
c'est pas une question critique
d'approvisionnement sur le sujet du gaz
rus on a fait la France a fait un boulot
incroyable vraiment j'ai sur la
planification écologique c'est-à-dire
que elle a eu le courage de mettre dans
les fameux mondriillants là dans un bon
gros tableau ce qu'il faut faire pour
dans chaque secteur arriver au net zéro
c'est-à-dire zéro carbone y compris en
compenser d'ici 2050 moi ce que
j'aimerais qu'on fasse maintenant je
reprends ma clé de voûte hordre de
grandeur
lucidité c'est qu'on se parle
franchement tous ensemble du fait de
savoir si c'est tenable et est faisable
et c'est extrêmement dur pas se poser la
question avant pardon fallait pas se
poser la question avant non mais on se
l'est posé au moment où on l'a fait
simplement en entre 2015 2016 lancement
de l'élaboration de ce plan et 10 ans
après entre
euh ce qui s'est passé aux États-Unis
euh nos nos propres problèmes euh des
missions qui ont avec le notamment la
question du nucléaire qui pendant un an
et demi a fait que on a orté davantage
nos courbes ont bougé notre la
transition qui est allé moins vite si je
prends la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments que ce qu'on pensait en terme
d'économie d'énergie et cetera et cetera
et cetera moi je enfin il faut qu'on
qu'on soit capable de revoir lucidement
nos courbes et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
souvent on l'a fait d'ailleurs dans la
le lapse de temps qu'on a regardé sur la
commission d'enquête on l'a fait à
plusieurs reprises vous avez votre vous
voulez atteindre un
point vous êtes là vous voulez atteindre
un point et donc vous avez une courbe
qui en moyenne doit ressembler à ça mais
au début typiquement c'était le cas pour
les énergies renouvelables elle est
beaucoup plus beaucoup moins raide que
prévu donc au lieu de changer votre
courbe au lieu de changer votre point
d'arrivée vous dites ah bah non on garde
le point d'arrivée mais la courbe va
être de plus en plus raide et ça c'est
pas très faisable et c'est pas très
réaliste donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on ait ce
moment de de discussion lucide avec
nous-même sur est-ce que c'est able ou
pas et pourquoi je parle de ça parce que
je parle du
gaz est-ce que on peut prétendre arriver
à quasi zéro en 50 en 55 ou en 60 et je
préfère qu'on se dise que ce sera plutôt
50 5 que 50 mais qu'on y arrive pourquoi
parce que il y a deux manières de voir
le net z0ro en 2050 il y a la manière de
voir le sommet de la
montagne et moi j'en ai un peu chez moi
quand vous faites de la haute montagne
et que vous vous allez vous essayez
d'atteindre un très au sommet le truc le
plus frustrant c'est que vous souvent
vous pouvez passer que quelques secondes
ou minutes au sommet parce que il faut
le temps de redescendre parce que vous
pouvez avoir des aléas et parce que
l'air est peu respirable surtout alors
moi je l'ai pas fait mais quand vous
alleer dans les très hautes montagnes en
Asie bon ça c'est pas le but hein enfin
moi je veux pas que la France arrive en
2050 en disant super on est à net zéro
par contre je peux plus respirer j'ai
plus d'industrie et on est on est en
décroissance depuis 10 ans moi mon but
c'est le rythme de croisière à partir de
2050 et donc si je l'atteins en 2052 ou
en 2061 mais que c'est du solide et ben
je préfère ça je signe pour ça beaucoup
plus que pour quelque chose de magique
et de sobre qui ne tient
pas les constructeurs automobiles vous
les avez reçu quand vous étiez au
ministre ils vous ont pas dit faut
arrêter vos conneries là
euh alors parmi les inconvénients d'être
ministre les gens sont sont polis avec
vous pourquoi c'est un inconvénient mais
parce qu'ils sont sont moins francs et
donc c'est après à vous de de de dans la
réunion que vous avez eu d'entendre ce
qu'on n pas pu vous dire pourquoi ils
sont moins francs parce qu'ils attendent
des largesses du ministre parce qu'ils
ont pas envie de de se parce qu'ils se
disent qu'un ministre ça peut être
susceptible que ils ont besoin de d'un
ministre sur d'autres dossiers et mais
je dis ça très sérieusement parce que ce
qui est très utile c'est quand il y a
quelqu'un qui vient dans votre bureau de
ministre hurler à la mort en vous disant
non mais là vous êtes complètement à
côté de la plaque parce que que là vous
vous dites que vous avez quelqu'un en
face de vous peut-être qu' fait du
cinéma mais c'est pas très important qui
pense que c'est suffisamment grave pour
dans une enceinte policée où tout le
monde va bien où on se demande si vous
prenez un café vous mettez du sucre dans
votre café ou pas viens vous dire
quelque chose de très important
l'automobile c'est le cas ça a été le
cas et moi un des dossiers que j'ai eu à
traiter qu'on a mis sur les rails c'est
le cas
aujourd'hui maintenant en tout cas c'est
l'annonce qu'a faite la commission c'est
des flexibilités pour que vous preniez
pas 15 milliards d'amendes sur les
constructeurs automobiles européens
parce qu'ils atteignent pas leurs
objectifs électriques et donc il
pourront encore moins investir et qui
seront encore plus à la Bour néanmoins
néanmoins je pense que c'était important
de le faire je suis content que ça se
fasse et cetera néanmoins notre
problème avec le l'automobile de manière
générale et notamment asiatique c'est
que on parlait de vitesse tout à l'heure
dans la course de vitesse on prend du
retard donc ne pas sanctionner les
nôtres parce qu'on prend du retard c'est
essentiel le contraire serait absurde ma
question que je me pose on reparle de
prospective c'est que ça c'est pour
l'année prochaine ça c'est le la
perspective du ministre politique
médiatique électorale mais ma vraie
préoccupation profonde comme ministre ça
doit être mais dans 15 ans est-ce que
j'ai une industrie automobile électrique
hybride hydrogène ou est-ce que j'ai
plus rien parce que j'ai tellement
décroché dans la course de vitesse que
j'ai pas de mine donc j'ai pas de
lithium
j'ai pas de semi-conducteur parce que
j'ai un peu lâché sur la l'usine qui
devait s'installer qui devait être le le
le faire de lance et puis sur
l'assemblage ben entre-temps mes
équipesentiers étant assassinés par les
amendes j'ai plus moi j'ai ça en haut de
Savoie la vallée du décoltage ils
travaillent pour le véhicule thermique
ils ont pas fait leur s'ils font pas
leur transition je les aurais plus et
donc demain j'auraai plus la chaîne de
valeur ça c'est la préoccupation le le
infra profonde qui doit nous animer
aujourd'hui je passe du cocalan ou
peut-être pas on a deux fournisseurs
d'énergie euh et de matières premières
qui deviennent hostiles ouvertement h
style côté Russie côté États-Unis
pendant le début de la guerre on a
rerouté sur du gaz naturel liqufié de de
gaz de schiste provenant des États-Unis
et ils nous font quatre fois le prix on
a un Trump hostile un Poutine hostile on
s'est fait boûter de d'Afrique
il nous reste quoi nos yeux pour pleurer
le dépissage sur les chiqui
international de la guerre économique il
nous reste quoi bah vous avez vous avez
bien résumé la chose euh ce qui était
possible hier face à la Russie ne le
sera pas demain ou en tout cas pas au
même
prix si ça AR au même prix parce que ils
vont ils vont se venger même s'il y a un
accord de paix ils vont nous mettre des
tarifs parce queon n' pas été
suffisamment
euh mais parce que ce ce ce qui nous
pose le plus de problèm je pense avec
l'administration Trump
euh c'est l'imprévisibilité le la la
démocratie européenne
classique mine de rien si si on prend un
tout petit si on si on essaie de faire
encore de l'autocritique et qu'on fait
un pas de recul si je me mets à la place
des États-Unis et que je regarde la
France l'Allemagne ou
l'Espagne ils savent quand sont les
prochaines élections
ils savent les probabilités que tel ou
tel arrive au pouvoir et la couleur
probable du Parlement parce qu'ils ont
des bons capteur parce qu'ils ont des
bons capteurs et puis parce qu'on est
assez
prévisible ils ont le le panel assez
exact à mon avis de ce qu'on est capable
de faire ou pas et notamment de ce que
l'Union Européenne à 27 est capable de
faire en 3 semaines 3 mois ou 3 ans bon
nous on a maintenant mat prière sans
énergie sans matiè nous on est
maintenant je pense qu'on peut le dire
si on n' pas été modeste hier il est
temps de l'être aujourd'hui on a assez
peu de certitude sur la fourchette
l'intervalle dans laquelle se trouve
l'administration Trump est-ce que vous
par ex enfin je vous question savoir
est-ce que vous vous diriez que on peut
être sûr demain que l'administration
Trump va pas finalement se ranger du
côté de l'Ukraine reprendre sa course
telle que c'était ou à l'inverse dire
attendez vous nous avez pas respecté
quand vous vous étiez dans le bureau
oval vous avez pas vous ne signez pas
l'accord sur les sur les minerais donc
désolé mais la Russie a raison et
basculé de en fait il n'y a pas de point
sur lequel on est absolument sûr et ça
pour la démocratie européenne classique
pour l'étalation de base c'est
destructeur
destructeur en terme d'agilité de
prospective première question est-ce que
vous avez vu Trump arrivriver au pouvoir
non puisque j'ai quitté le enfin vous
voulez dire est-ce que j'ai j'ai
non non est-ce que vous avez senti que
Trump allait avoir un mandat plein et
entier de de son
peuple alors ça m MRE de dire oui parce
que je vais avoir l'air prétentieux mais
si vous dites oui je vais vous demander
pourquoi en fait je vais vous dire oui
et je vais vous dire pourquoi j'ai eu ce
sentiment
là on a depuis des anné et on continue à
le faire aujourd'hui compris en France
tu veux te moucher vas-y sans faire
on
a on on lit les résultats de ce qu'on
appelle les populistes avec des lunettes
d'antipopuliste
donc en fait on ne comprend pas les
moteurs de leur succès donc quand Trump
s'est radicalisé je sais pas s'il faut
dire radicalisé vous voyez ce que je
veux dire quand Trump c'est a été plus
loin quand dans son vocabulaire dans ce
qu'il disait il a changé de de tonalité
ou de ou de lexique quand il s'est mis à
changer d'avis en 5 jours
manifestement nous on en a tous déduit
la
décrédibilisation le manque de respect
et qu'est-ce qu'on s'est dit
disqualification parce que on a notre
portrait robot du dirigeant de
démocratie occidentale et on est loin
très loin de ce qui fait aujourd'hui le
moteur électoral des gens qui vont voter
c'est-à-dire le sentiment que
malheureusement le système est à bout
souffle et que ce qui est crédible ceux
qui sont crédibles ce sont ceux qui ne
sont surtout pas comme le système et qui
ne correspondent en rien au portrait
robot et donc plus il s'éloignaient plus
il creusaient l'écart et les sondage en
tout cas aux États-Unis l'ont assez mal
capté dans les dernières semaines parce
qu'il le lisaient avec les mêmes
lunettes que nous la la la bonne société
américaine le lisait avec les mêmes
lunettes que nous comment le type qui ne
condamne pas le Capitol qui traite un
ski de tous les noms qui nous insulte
une fois sur deux qui veut annexer le
Groenland comment compris pourquoi il
voulait le Groenland non mais comment
oui enfin en tout cas j'ai quelques bon
comment est-ce que j'ai compris aussi
pour le Panama en tout cas ça donne on
parlait de
matérialité on avait on don un peu de
matérialité comment quelqu'un qui dit
des choses qui sont aussi au-delà de
notre cadre peut-il faire plus de voix
mais enfin c'est exactement comme ça
qu'il a fait sa première voix donc on n
pas compris le système marginal mais pe
parce que vous avez peut-être mal lu
Obama Clinton et Biden Trump dit
peut-être les choses directement comme
un un vendeur
d'appartement alors que les autres
présentai ça pour aller libérer les
petites filles la démocratie apporter la
démocratie pour les copains libérer les
femmes alors que derrière c'était
business TER rare et puis pétrole al 100
% d'accord deux éléments pour aller dans
ce
sens-là qui sont un peu contradictoire
pardon mais je pense qu'ils sont tous
les deux en fait importants le premier
c'est qu'il y a une tendance lourde
j'allais dire multiséculaire américaine
qui fait que après des phases
d'expansionnisme il y a des phases
d'isolationisme qui avait commencé
socialement sociétalement aux États-Unis
avant Trump et le deuxième point et la
tendance lourde alors là isolationistme
ou expansif qui a toujours été vrai
c'est business is business et juste
avant l'arrivée de Trump au pouvoir
l'administration Biden que moi j'ai
rencontré quand j'étais ministre
prévoyait de la législation
extraterritoriale sur l'automobile et
notamment sur les appareils connectés
qu'il y a dans l'automobile bon il
l'exprimaent juste poliment avec leur
mots avec des procédures classiques mais
c'est des choses que nous Européens on n
pas le droit de faire ou en tout cas qui
ne sont pas dans notre range des option
de
l'UE continuer sur Trump et donc
euh Trump il est déjà avant d'avoir dit
un mot l'héritier de cette double
tendance expansionisme économique et
isolationnisme politique et donc avant
même d'avoir d'être Trump il est
l'américain sous un
visage portrait robot et puis qu'est-ce
qu'il y ajoute à mon sens il y ajoute
l'imprévisibilité et ce qui va avec
l'imprévisibilité il y ajoute le le
en fait c'est comme dans les jeux vidéos
euh le Trump 1 et Trump 2 Trump 1 c'est
vous savez vous êtes dans un jeu vidéo
et vous prenez je condamne la violence
sous toutes ses formes euh dans le c'est
pour ça que vous êtes ici ex exactement
dans le dans le dans le dans la premiier
dans la première partie il prend une
arme un peu random genre pistolet
mitrailleur et il visent très mal il
tire beaucoup de cartouches ça met du
temps à recharger et du coup il loupe
les zombies quoi bon en gros et à la fin
on se dit tout ça pour ça dans le deè
euh dans le 2è mandat il choisit un
fusil à pompe ça recharge encore moins
vite mais il il tire beaucoup moins de
mal il passe son temps à dire qu'il va
en tirer et quand il en tire une ça fait
très très mal parce que en fait il a eu
4 ans de mandat plus 4 ans où il était
pas président d'expérience de manière de
présenter les choses et il est entouré
de sniper c'est difficile de dire que
Trump et V ne sont pas des snipers ce
qui s'est passé dans le hovalofice avec
ski je sais pas si c'est une embuscade
je sais pas à quel point c'est prémédité
mais V a choisi ses mots avec une
précision et une acuité et une capacité
d'escalade qui sont évidentes donc euh
tout ce qui va c'est je fais le lien
avec le truc électoral tout ce qui va
dans le sens de mépriser euh se
méprendre se euh disqualifier Trump
montre qu'on est encore dans le logiciel
de compréhension qui est complètement
anachronique aux US et sans doute un
jour en europeope ça va durer combien de
temps le fait qu'on nit pas les bonnes
lunettes le bon microscope les bons
capteurs pour comprendre ce qui nous
entoure ça ça il y a péril en la demeure
oui ça dép on a pas d'énergie ou du
moins on est un peu plus protégé grâce
au général de Gaul Pompidou et Bernard
et
sambert nucléire oui
euh les autres en Europe l'Allemagne est
dans une mouille c'est pas possible
son industrie est en train de rendre à
lâ ses constructeurs on a des copains
chez Audi chez BMW qui nous tiennent au
courant que ça commence à piquer sé verr
là il se il prévoi 500 milliards pour se
réarmer protéger leur industrie il y a
pas d'énergie on n pas encore la fusion
ils ont pas les matières premières ils
ont du charbon on va faire quoi
là alors le le cas allemand est assez
intéressant évidemment et il est assez
euh illustratif de la question qu'on se
pose plus généralement sur il y a péril
dans la demeure comment est-ce qu'on va
se réveiller
euh je l'ai vu comme député encore plus
je suis très germanophile j'aime
l'Allemagne j'y vais régulièrement je
l'ai vu encore plus comme ministre euh
il y a une forme de d'aveuglement je
prends spécifiquement le cas de
l'automobile parce qu'on a eu des
discussions
dessus en gros pour le dire de manière
caricaturale j'ai le
sentiment que un certain dirigeants ne
comprennent pas que les quelques niches
qui demeurent en Asie et aux US sur
certains segments de l'automobile plus
plus premium ne valent pas la ruine du
reste et donc ne valent pas la porte
ouverte à tout à toutes les fenêtres le
manque de de d'infrastructure de
matériaux et d'énergie
et ça me fait penser à un directeur de
la concurrence je crois de la Commission
européenne un belge qui avait dit en
j'ai peur de me tromper mais dans la
décennie 2010 euh l'Europe n'a pas
besoin d'industrie lourde il avait dit
vraiment comme
ça avec l'idée qu'au fond c'était comme
un bilan d'entreprise il suffit de se
répartir les couches à toi
l'infrastructure et les minerais parce
que c'est assez désagréable de
l'extraire chez nous et à nous les
logiciels et cetera bon l'histoire a
montré qu'à chaque fois que on pensait
être l'innovateur et laisser à l'autre
la basse besogne on perdait tout euh à
la fin
donc je pense pour le coup que le covid
qui aurait dû être un réveil beaucoup
plus fort en tout cas un wake up call
beaucoup plus important que ce qu'on a
vécu
euh sera suivi d'une manière ou d'une
autre je sais pas s'il faut parler de
crise parce que c'est un terme tellement
dévoyé mais par un réveil matériel ou
énergétique ou matériel ou les deux très
fort il y a pas besoin d'une nouvelle
crise d'une nouvelle pandémie pour ne
plus voir le comment dirais-je pour pour
pour voir que les chaînes de valeur
peuvent être brisées en un instant et
que si les semi-conducteur ou le lithium
cesse d'être livré à des plaques
continentales c'est les 2/ers de de
l'économie industrielle qui sont mises à
l'arrêt là on a traité le premier
fournisseur béliqueux imprévisible pour
vous pour le les gens C SAÉ faire des
anticipations passons au fournisseur
hostile de Poutine qu'est-ce qu'on
fait déjà pourquoi on a pas vu la guerre
venir déjà pourquoi on a pris des des
mesures de sanction symptomatiqu dans la
précipitation dans l'agitation pourquoi
on s'est tiré une balle dans le pied
tout de
suite je je connais moins et mal pour
être très honnête la Russie vous avez
déjà été en Russie j'ai été une fois en
Russie à pb Saint-Pétersbourg c'est je
connais pas c'est joli c'est magnifique
pour c'est quoi là-bas du tourisme céit
en quelle année vous avez été tamponné
par le KGB euh c'était tiens juste une
question avant histoire de de vous
déconcentrer un petit peu quand on est
ministre de l'économie française
puissance de moyenne impuissance
mondiale 5e 4e 8e appelez ça quel rang
vous voulez vous avez un briefing des
services pour votre téléphone portable
vos communications votre copine chinoise
votre copine russe votre copine
américaine
oui et vos assistants ils sont briefés
pareil oui proprement
oui je vous avez quoi comme téléphone un
ça j' euh là ouais ce que j'ai là moi
maintenant un iPhone c'est
con après j'avais un autre téléphone
quand j'étais la
valisette j'avais mais ça je pense que
vous l'avez déjà vu et je suis pas assez
expert en la matière pour gr le nom une
une oui ça ressemblait d' une valisette
à berc dans mon bureau pour mettre les
téléphones et refermer
oui je pense que c'est une carad en
effet vous aviez récupéré le bureau
d'Emmanuel Macron l'espèce de petit
bureau bien sombre juste à côté de
l'ascenseur pour monter sur l'éliport
alors moi j'ai le j'avais le bureau de
Bruno leire parce que je j'étais
ministre des Finances et Emmanuel Macron
avait le avait le bureau du ministre de
l'Industrie qui est au
traditionnellement au 3e étage et puis
il y a le 5e étage moi j'étais au 6e 5e
étage il le bureau du ministre des
comptes publics vous avez fait un tour
sur
l'éliport sert jamais pas fait de tour
sur l'éliport mais je l'avais déjà fait
quand j'étais à ber mais effectivement
il ne sert jamais avec les le vent créé
par la BnF c'était quoi ma question je
reviens à votre question sur la Russie
en général et en particulier
euh et et je commence par la de mémoire
la deuxème sur
euh pourquoi est-ce qu'on a pris lestion
à précipit alors pourquoi on a rien
venir euh à nouveau je peux pas malheure
alors si je prends 2014 je j'étais pas
en état de de enfin j'étais pas dans un
comment diraisje à un niveau
d'information ou de connaissance ou de
participation ni publique ni
professionnelle qui me permet de
répondre correctement à votre question
j'ai essayé de le faire tout à l'heure
en disant je pense qu'il y a des
éléments mais bon euh sur les sanctions
européennes en fait pour l'avoir vu dans
d'autres domaines à différen à
différents endroit l'Europe n' si je le
dis crumement l'Europe n'avance que dans
la précipitation et que dans les
réponses face aux crises et dans le
symptomatique et dans la
panique panique je sais pas dans le
symptomatique forcément puisque elle ne
réagit que par la crise et donc elle
n'accepte enfin en tout cas le système
européen ne réagit que au symptômes pour
avoir une légitimité pour le faire mais
quand on dit l'Europe il y a trois
choses dedans moins il y en a plus mais
moi je vois au moins trois ingrédients
qui trois éléments qui sont assez
différents vous avez un
l'Union
européenne 30000 fonctionnaires une
présidence de commission avec des
influen diverses et varié en fonction
des pays et des
nominations qui a un déficit
démocratique évident et doncmoctique oui
pardon oui un déficite démocratique
évident puisque c'est une personnalité
qui est choisie et qui est confirmée par
le Parlement européen par je parle de
tous les présidents de manière générale
on voit bien ité on ne veut pas déléguer
notre souveraineté entièrement à
l'Europe et donc il est pas question
qu'il y ait un président ou une
présidente pour le moment de l'Union
européenne qui soit élu au suffrage
universel mais dans le même temps on se
plaint à juste titre d'avoir quelqu'un
qui incarne l'Europe et qui n'a pas été
élu directement donc vous avez l'Union
européenne qui est quand même à la
manœuvre pour la plupart des décisions
quotidiennes au long cours technique on
pourra parler Green Deal on pourra
parler défense politique commerciale
défense des intérêts doiniers et cetera
et C et ca vous avez la banque centrale
qui est indépendante mais qui enfin
c'est pas ici que je vais le dire parce
que regardez plus que moi le système
international qui joue un rôle énorme de
stabilisateur de politiqu monétaire au
sens où je pense que les choix qui ont
été fait ces dernières années ont évité
au moment les au moment cruciaux qu'on
ait un dérapage ou inflationniste ou
d'emploi et vous avez le troisième
élément qu'on oublie trop souvent qui
est l'Europe depuis toujours et qui le
sera pour toujours quels que soi les
conditions institutionnelles qui sont la
réunion des États européens et euh quand
François Baayou lundi au débat sur
l'Ukraine disait puis la phrase exacte
nous sommes plus forts que ce que nous
le pensons il a surtout dit que il
venait de comprendre que nos alliés
c'était peut-être pas nos alliés alors
qu'on s'est fait dépouiller à stom qu'on
s'est fait dépouiller
[Musique]
Technip plus la formule qu'il a employé
mais du point de vue économique oui on
est on est tous coupable Dee naïveté on
appelle ça des perdreux de l'année chez
nous euh c'est bon le perd et ce sont
les plombs c'est de préférence
euh je reprends le fil oui donc quand il
dit nous ça plus fort qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que au fond ce
troisème élément il ne tient qu'à nous
de le mettre en en en application et
pourquoi je dis ça parce que je suis pas
un fan de l'Union européenne au sens où
je considère que l'objet supplente tout
et que on est anti-européen si on
critique l' ça c'est complètement débile
et d'ailleurs c'est un piège dans lequel
on est tombé très souvent on n'ose plus
critiquer l' sous prétexte qu'on est
pro-européen donc on laisse l' faire des
bêtises dans le rayon bêtisse je suis
sûr qu'on pourra prendre un moment ici
ailleur pour en parler mais beaucoup de
gens ont beaucoup d'exemples bon deux
exemples de bêtises
euh deux exemples de bêtises bon une
assez une qui me vient assez
naturellement sur le nucléaire qui est
de persécuter pardon le terme est un peu
fort mais de persécuter la France depuis
des décennies euh je l'ai vécu ça je je
suis à je suis à Bruxelles on négocie un
papier sur la compétitivité qui n'a rien
à voir avec le sujet et on me dit que
mon homologue allemand des Finances
bloque parce que il y a low carbon
energies c'est en anglais énergie bac
carbone dans le papier
et qui veut qu'on les fasse et qu'on
mette renewables énergie renouvelable
bon quand vous êtes un adulte
responsable dans la pièce vous dites on
va peut-être pas y passer 2
heur pourquoi pas laissons tomber c'est
pas le sujet moi je suis peut-être pas
tout à fait adulte ou pas toujours
totalement responsable donc je dis non
non on va prendre le temps qu'il faut
mais bon c'est ce c'est ce type de
d'anecdote qui me permet d'illustrer le
long terme de l'Europe sur le nucléaire
qui est qui était en fait largement mené
par l'Allemagne par l'Autriche
l'Autriche a mis dans sa constitution
qu'il était interdit d'avoir du
nucléaire donc on est on n'est pas sur
des des positions légères on est sur des
choses extrêmement lourdes et quasi
identitaires vous avez pris vous avez vu
le prix de l'électricité en Autriche en
ce moment
j'ai pas vu dernièr les services vous
avez prévenu que les Allemands ils
essayent de nous torpiller une notre
nucléaire par l'intermédiaire d'ONG par
l'intermédiaire de lobbying pour pour
réduire notre compétitivité on a
vu on l'a vu pendant la commission
d'enquête je l'ai vu aussi avant mais on
on voit que
euh il a il y a un truc qui est assez
aussi désagréable c'est de voir que
souscouvert de partenariat
franco-allemand pour les énergies
renouvelables il s'agit de ne pas parler
de ce de ce qui nous met en désaccord
donc la présentation un peu typique et
polie c'est de
dire ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
pas parler de ce qui nous gêne on va
parler du reste mais je reviens à mes
ordres de grandeur moi il se trouve que
je suis député d'un pays dont 75 % de
l'électricité vient du
nucléaire bon je veux bien qu'on parle
pas de ce qui fait que je suis le pays
avec le bilan carbone électrique le plus
propre d'Europe à l'exception peut-être
de la Norvège ou de ou de autres pays
qui ont beaucoup d'hydroélectricité et
cetera mais en fait je reviens à ma clé
de voû de grandeur dans ce cas-là c'est
pas la peine de se parler si on fait
joujou sur les quelques points de
pourcentage de photovoltaïque qui n'ont
pas besoin d'une coopération
internationale incroyable pour se
développer ça veut dire qu'on se parle
pas des vrais sujets et là je reviens à
un autre affaire de trè élément ça c'est
le travail des chefs d'État des
ministres et des hommes ou des femmes
politiques j'allais dire de se
confronter mais de s'engueuler de se
dire ben on n pas d'accord là-dessus
mais on a besoin les conditions de
puissance de l'Europe passe par
l'énergie c'est P ça ass net donc si une
des conditions de puissance fondamental
n'est pas réunie on peut beaucoup se
parler d'Europe puissance
mais je peux vous poser une question
si ça c'est la deuxième bonne
blague si vous étiez à la place de Bruno
Lemer lors du départ du conflit
russo-ukrainien vous auriez
dit sur les réseaux sociaux à la télé
nous allons mettre l'économie russe à
genou en connaissant l'intrication de
notre système énergétique de matière
première l'intrication la dépendance il
connaissait pas il l'a dit sous le coup
de l'émotion il l'a répété parce que ça
sonnait bon je peux pas répondre pour
lui évidemment je vous auriez dit ça va
je sais pas non plus et pardon je dis
juste ça sans sans vouloir esquiver he
mais je dis pas ça non plus pour
esquiver mais je je on sait jamais dans
gen circonstance si il y a pas une
position diplomatique qui fait qu'on lui
demande ou qu'on demande à un ministre
de d'avoir une position très peut-être
euh je sais pas si c'est parce qu'on ne
connaî connaissait pas à l'époque o
qu'on avait pas compris pardon les
intentions et l'ampleur et la profondeur
de ce qui allait se passer qu'on a dit
ça mais on a fait mal à l'économie russe
c'est en fait je lisais un économiste de
de
l'EdN Institut des ha études de défense
national en gros les sensions 5 points
de PIB rus les jeunes de l'ODN aussi il
faut les voir ils font très bon boulotou
absolument donc 5 points de PIB bonè
c'est très dou dououreux et je parle pas
des questions financières et cetera bon
c'est
important maintenant moi qui suis enfin
j'espère que ce tout soupçon pour
l'intégrité territoriale la défense des
frontières et qui donc souhaite bien sûr
et souhaite que les démocratie se
défendent et à l'image de l'Ukraine
tienneent je prends un tout petit peu de
recul sur notre histoire et je pense que
le la Russie de Vladimir Poutine et la
Russie d'après Vladimir Poutine quelqu
soit le nom de son
dirigeant ne peut pas rester
éternellement un ennemi de un
adversairire de cet ordre là et voir un
etnemi sinon on court au drame européens
pour pourquoi en terme de business en
terme de guerre en terme de quoi parce
que
euh je mets la Russie un tout petit peu
de côté quand je prends cette image
mondiale parce que c'est 2100 ou
2050 milliards en valent dollar de PIB
c'est 150 millions d'habitants c'est un
territoire gigantesque mais c'est ni la
Chine ni les États-Unis donc quand vous
avez deux tendance très lourde un
tendance lourde US isolationnisme et
puissance intérieure et donc prête à des
attaques commerciales ou à de l'offensif
sans limite et de la Chine qui peut
prendre le beau rôle c'est que ce qui
est incroyable sais pas si vous le
ressentez comme moi ce qui est
incroyable ces temps-ci c'est que avec
la position de Trump
c'est shinping qui vient dire le
multilatéralisme c'est important et le
respect du libre commerce c'est
important donc l'inversion des valeurs
est totale et totalement possible sauf
que les nouvelles routes de la soie
c'est pas exactement du Do commmerce les
infrastructures critiques dans certains
ports africains ou européens qui sont
littéralement acheté avec des conditions
qui sont directement politiques c'est
pas du dou commerce donc face à ça il y
a une plaque
européano euh asiatique je sais pas
comment il faut l'exprimer qui n'inclut
pas la Chine qui doit exister et là je
qui disait le Général de l'Atlantique
àoural qui en tout cas quelque chose qui
là je parle d'une temporalité qui est du
siècle ou plus et des décennies à venir
et et dire ça il faut il faut pas
laisser caricaturer le débat c'està dire
que il faut faut il faut faut
s'interdire de de de de de ne pas dire
les choses sur l'enjeu à 50 ou 100 ans
la Chine je pense que la Chine je je je
prends le risque on en' reparle dans 50
ans ou 30 ans mais je je prends je
prends le risque de dire que je pense
que la Chine dans 30 ans aura un mode de
gouvernance assez semblable euh sera
toujours un immense pays avec une
immense histoire qui l'amène à avoir un
une ambition et un appétit gigantesque
et que les États-Unis continueront à
être traversés par leur pulsion
isolationniste donc c'est à nous on sera
où là et nous on sera euh vous voyez
c'est c'est vraiment comme comme dans
les scénarios prospectifs des agence
économique énergétique démographique gen
vous parlez de laquelle de la CIA vous
parlez de de de non mais vous voyez par
exemple euh vous parliez d'exponentiel
tout à l'heure c'est moins vrai là c'est
plus linéire mais euh avec ind
différence de deux ou trois deg degrés
d'angle aujourd'hui on peut être à des
endroits très différents dans 40 ans je
fais le scénario positif
exceptionnellement vous vous vous
m'inter j'espère bien si dans 4 j'is
aussi surtout le scénario réaliste
oui si dans 40 ans
euh on a développé la 3e ou la 4e
génération nucléaire inchallah euh qu'on
a comme vous dites qu'on a dans
l'alliier au fin fond de l'Allier ouvert
une mine de lithium qui fait euh un un
pourcentage colossal des véhicules
électriques qu'on produire en France ou
en Europe et qu'on en a ouvert d'autres
parce que on on a vu que le BRGM le
bureau de recherche logique Pier a
actualisé son inventaire et a trouvé
d'autres matériaux que on a réduit notre
dépendance au gaz au gaz au pluriel de
différents pays en faisant du biogaz
exactement en faisant du biogaz en
Europe mais ça suffira pas à tout
combler et en gardant une partie de gaz
si c'est nécessaire qu'on a développé
certaines industries d'avant-garde et
qu'on a utilisé des énergies type
nucléaire hydro ou autrees pour avoir
des serveurs qui nous permettent d'avoir
nos propres industries digitales en
France et qu'on a toujours de
l'armement et qu'on a toujours notre
marché qu'on a consolidé aux frontières
parce qu'on a fait des accords
commerciaux avec l'Asie centrale avec
l'Amérique du Sud avec certains pays
africains qui ont changé de dimension en
30 ou 40 ans on est quoi on est un
continent d'équilibre économique et
attractif parce qu'on garde les valeurs
et l'éducation et la culture qui sont
les nôtres le scénario réaliste est
peut-être
plus
noir dans quelle proportion ah il peut
ça peut être une question de nature ou
de degré j'imagine c'est-à-dire que ça
peut être ou ou aujourd'hui en pire
ou pire ben aujourd'hui en pire c'est
que des pénuriie des coupures
d'électricité avec une industrie qui
plonge des fonctionnaires pas payés des
retraites pas payées avec une sécu
inexistante avec des pharmacies en
pénurie avec des références 153
références en pharmacie qui n'existent
plus avec du paracétamol coupé aux
arbres de Provence comment voilà en fait
ce que j'aime bien dans vos exemples
même s'ils sont inquiétants ils sont pas
inquiétants ils sont juste réalistes
mais ils sont en tout cas ils sont
concrets ce que j'aime bien c'est qu'ils
sont concrets et qu' ils sont ils
illustrent ce qu'on voit déjà en fait
c'est un appauvrissement relatif de la
France alors c'est vrai aussi en Europe
mais je v prendre un exemple parmi
d'autres le prix des restaurants ou de
l'immobilier et ben en fait il est
important en France et en Europe mais il
décroche par rapport aux États-Unis
parce que c'est un symptôme parmi
d'autres de la consommation courante et
queil y a un appauvrissement natif donc
la question moi je la question dans
votre question que j'ajoute c'est quels
sont les secteurs qu'on va sacrifier les
premiers autrement dit qu'est-ce qu'on
va vraiment garder jusqu'au bout est-ce
qu'on voudra avoir des médicaments
remboursés à quasi 100 % jusqu'au bout
quiit à ne plus avoir de retraite ou
avoir des salaires en berne ou est-ce
qu'au contraire ce sera euh
la consommation courante les produits
qu'on voudra pas taxer même s'ils sont
importés qu'on veut avoir en ligne de
mire donc je pense que dans votre
scénario il y a plein de
sous-scénarios mais qui ont tous comme
point commun si pas de redressement
industriel et économique alors
appauvrissement qui se matérialise
qu'est-ce qu' je vous laisse prendre
votre verre d'eau vous pouvez
prendre on est grand prince ici
ouais vous faites une belle diversion
d'ailleurs comment va comment va se
comporter l'Europe comment va se
comporter la zone euro surtout comment
va se comporter
l'euro sans énergie sans matières
premières avec des dettes qui explosent
comment ça va se passer sur les fonds
nos fonds nos dettes est-ce qu'on va se
faire attaquer par notre fournisseur
énergétique béliqueux de gauche les
fonds souverains agressifs de droite
comment ça va se passer est-ce que nos
amis européens ont essayé de faire des
des
scénarios en mode tempête en mode
j'enlève mes lunettes roses en mode on
va chercher les meilleurs limiers et on
va chercher les
les les gens qui regardent les choses en
face et qui nous font des
scénarios pas des scénarios à continuer
les petites lignes sur des salons
feutrés de moquettees de 3 cm
d'épaisseur à lever des petits doigts
pour boire le thé à s'échanger des
cartes de visite en faisant très cher
quand est-ce qu'on va envoyer dans les
cabinets de prospective économique
européen français ce que vous voulez on
va faire venir les vilains garçons on va
faire venir les les bas de Boy pour
secouer tous ces ce rondrond quotidien
pour être très poli parce que là on va
se faire menacer nos dettes parce que on
annonce la Banque centrale européenne
800 milliards pour le réarmement c'est
très bien l'industrie de l'éarmement
l'industrie de l'armement explose plus
15 + 17 % en une journée do peut-être
d'avoir des Chinois qui vont se faire de
l'argent
dedans nos dettes basé sur rien mis à
part nos valeurs la main sur le cœur
draper dans les tendards de la liberté
ça ça vaut pour les salons feutrés de s
tank quand est-ce qu'on fait venir les
bad boys
là alors parenthèse sur les 110 des des
800 milliards là c'est un truc j'allais
dire un truc
les 1600 km c'est un truc et astuce très
administratif et technocratique que moi
j'aime pas trop qui consiste à habillet
pour faire une grosse somme bon en fait
dans les 800 les 800 milliards dont il
parle de quoi on parle on parle de 650
milliards qui correspondent à une
augmentation des dépenses de dépenses de
chaque état des dépenses militaires de
chaque État donc ça c'est un peu do it
by
yourself en français faites-le par
vous-même merci et c'est au fond l'idée
que on va demander on va supposer que
les États le font très bien mais ça
c'est rien de neuf sous le soleil en bon
et 150 milliards potentiellement qui
viendrait en plus mais chronologiquement
avant pendant après pas très clair de
près bon donc déjà on a un peu
démystifié le on a un peu démystifié le
chiffre je le dis parce que je me
souviens du plan Junker et des plans qui
ont suivi d'investissement où on disait
1000 milliards bon enfin le français
moyen que je suis se disait à l'époque
bon bah avec 1000 milliards d'euros
d'investissement on est sauvé on va
pouvoir faire trois plans bon ben de
fait c'est pas c'est vrai c'est pas du
milliard frais et disponible tel qu'on
l'entend maintenant je reviens à votre
question fondamentale les bad boy du bad
boy on l'a mon s mon intuition mon
sentiment mon impression c'est qu'on l'a
fait un peu voire pas mal sur la partie
bancaire c'est-à-dire que on a pris euh
la crise de 2008 des les crises à partir
2008 de plein fouet et donc on a posé la
question de la supervision et de la
résolution bancaire qui maintenant à mon
avis en terme de pendule nous ont
conduit à un déficit de compétitivité du
secteur financiers européens par rapport
aux États-Unis et on en reparlera si
vous voulez mais on a posé ce sujet et
on en on en parle en détail c'est-à-dire
les fonds propres la doit B 1 3 ce que
les Américains ont appelé les run les
banques run c'est-à-dire que comme tout
le monde comme tous les banques comme
toutes les banques se prêtent et on peur
en même temps quand vous allez tirer des
sous au distributeur il y a plus rien et
là c'est la panique et c'est
l'écroulement généralisé donc on a
essayé de faire des mécanismes de
supervision pour regarder ce qui se
passe quand il y a il y a un problème et
puis de de résolution c'est-à-dire de
s'assurer que les banques ne s'écroule
pas et potentiellement de les surabonder
mais alors deux choses premièrement
là-dessus les les grandes banques
europées eurne vous dites tous on on on
asphixie la compétitivité du secteur
financier européen sans régler les vrais
problèm qui risque d'arriver aux banques
s'il a un problème je mets ça un tout
petit peu de côté pour pour aller encore
plus loin sur la partie des
dettes on n pas eu de problème très
inquiétants sur le refinancement de not
dette tel que l'Europe s'en est saisi ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui en tête euh c'est
des difficultés de coû enfin sur le coût
de financement euh c'est euh que des
choses que regarde la Banque centrale
européenne mais que d'autres regardent
c'est des inquiétudes de possibles
petites attaques que vous décriviez mais
alors là peut-être en dehors
malheureusement de la partie orientale
qui viendrait de d'un peu partout
d'investisseurs qui viennent moins qui
se retirent euh il y a un élément il y a
au moins deux éléments qu'on na pas pris
en compte ou pas assez le premier celui
que vous avez mentionné c'est les le les
vilains garçons comme vous disiez qui
viennent vous faire vous mettre devant
les yeux ce qui pourrait se passer de
vraiment grave si vous avez des attaques
j'ajoute un mot mais je pense que vous s
entendiez
coordonner à de différentes places pour
arriver et la deuxième chose qu'on n'
pas en tête qui est là à mon avis c'est
plus la mer qui remonte au monts-michel
et ça a l'air lent mais à la fin c'est
très rapide comment ça s'appelle les
phénomènes de Maré comme ça qui qui
monent au Galot mas carré une mas carré
oui effectivement et et ça ça une un
sousjacent aujourd'hui c'est que
l'endettement mondial croit et est-ce
que est-ce que on peut imaginer que les
que les les le financement de la
l'appétit pour la dette va croître
autant bah ça dépend alors la dette
américaine est soutenue par son armée la
dette chinoise est soutenue par
oui et sont et sont marché intérieur
enfin
la dette russe est soutenue par ses
ressources la dette
européenne elle est soutenue par nos
belles
gueules elle est soutenue par
elle est soutenue alors encore nos beau
sourire non mais oui mais ça a une
traduction économique qui est que elle
est soutenue par ce qu'on appelle
improprement le marché intérieur mais
elle est soutenue par le fait que
l'Europe est peuplée de gens en
comparaison internationale riche et qui
consomme ou qui épargne mais dans les
deux cas ça nous arrange pour la dette
donc c'est c'est ce sous-jacent là qui
est qui l'a fait le lien avec ce qu'on
disait au tout début le contraste entre
les finances publiques et l'économie
c'est-à-dire que on peut se retrouver
dans une situation a une économie qui
vivote et des finances publiques qui se
dégradent le problème c'est que ça ça
peut tenir mais à la fin vous avez
évidemment perdu sur les deux tableau
parce que le jour où l'économie décroche
ou lâche bah vous avez plus que les
finances publiques dégradées deux
questions qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
stacflation la stacflation
euh c'est la combinaison de deux
phénomènes un peu contradictoires en
économie la stagnation économique et
l'inflation autrement dit je prends
cette comparaison parce que on me l'a
toujours apprise comme ça et je la
trouve intéressante c'est que on peut
imaginer que l'économie est un moteur ou
une route vélo avec des vitesses que
vous passez et chacun sait la difficulté
quand vous êtes en sour régime ou en
surrégime quand vous êtes en sous-régime
si je prends le vélo quand vous êtes en
sous-régime c'est extrêmement dur de
pédaler vous devez faire un effort
énergétique colossal pour avancer c'est
pas rentable et puis à la fin ça vous
finissez par reculer quand vous êtes en
surrégime c'est la roue qui risque de se
casser bon là le le monde de la
staflation c'est un ronde où vous vous
appauvrissez parce qu'il y a de
l'inflation mais vous vous ne vous
enrgissez pas par la production par
ailleurs et c'est un peu ce qu'on se
décrit là sur le le couple infernal
finances publi je voudrais que vous n
parliez du fond de garantie des dépôts
bancaires en
France combien de comptes garanties
jusqu'à combien et combien
d'établissements combien de comptes par
établissement alors j'ai un petit doute
sur l'acronyme vous allez me le
confirmer est-ce que c'est bien la
déclinaison française et nationale du
fond de résolution et du fond enfin des
obligations prudentielles européennes
sur les garanties de dépôts
c'est un d'après mes souvenirs le fond
de garantie des dépôts
bancaires c'est quand les banques se
vutre oui et c'est jusqu'à 15000 10000
150000 € c'est ça non c'est 72000 € par
compte et par établissement
d'accord quand on a du temps de Monsieur
sapin on lui avait demandé combien ce
fond était
provisionné on s'était rendu compte que
ça couvrait pas beaucoup de comptes en
banque oui
le garanti des dépôts de titre non ça
c'est
après ça il nous a sorti mais vous
inquiétez pas l'état fera un effet de
levier sur ce
fond quand on est obligé d'activer le
fond de garantie des dépôts bancaires
que le VIX est au plafond que la
signature de la France est mise à mal
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ah vous avez décrit le le scénario euh
bad boy le de bad boy comme vous dites
de de vilain garçon euh
enfin vous décrivez les scénarios où le
le le contrôle élémentaire de la
souveraineté financière n'est plus
assuré
euh alors si j'essaie de
creuser je sais pas chronologiquement
s'il faut partir de d'une des des des
des Français qui vont tirer leur argent
en quant en banque ou s'il faut partir
du refinancement enfin vous voyez il y a
deux manières de faire si on part si je
pars de la situation concrète des gens
qui se disent ce pays n'est plus tenu je
vais récupérer mon argent et et et le
garder sous mon matelas euh ça va très
vite et
euh l'État en fait là à mon avis on
passe dans un monde où les banques
centrale en l'occurrence la Banque
Centrale Européenne a une marge
d'interprétation de s de son règlement
de son statut pour abonder dans dans un
scénario qu'on na jamais vu et ça ça
fait le lien avec ce que vous disiez je
suis pas capable de vous répondre
simplement je ne suis pas sûr que ce
scénario soit totalement expertisé et
totalement comment dirais-je décliné
opérationnellement sur le sur le mode et
si dans 2 ans si je parle envoyer Bruno
le merire il va faire des bonnes
prospectives expliquer si je parle de
l'autre côté
euh en fait si je parle de l'autre côté
c'est pire parce
que si on narrive plus à non pas payer
les intérêts de la dette mais si on
arrive plus à se refinancer sur les
marchés
étant donné le poids de notre dette
l'année dernière enfin sous mon
administration on a on a fait un
programme d'émission de 300 milliards si
on arrive plus à émettre enfin pas à
émettre mais à à financer la dette ou
faire acheter notre
dette ça veut dire que la confiance
enfin ça veut dire qu'on est la
grèe et
ça dans un pays de 60 millions
d'habitants qui sont pas vraiment prêts
à moin 25 % sur les salaires des
fonctionna d'après ce que j'ai cru
comprendre
etraite à 70 ans et de la retraite
exactement mais on s'approche de ce que
vous avez pas dit mais de ce que vous
avez suggéré et et investigué dans
d'autres entretien c'est que la
dimension financière redevient une
dimension sociale ou sociétale c'est que
et d'ailleurs je fais une parenthèse je
je parce que ça m'a un peu
traumatisé quand j'étais à ber
le moment où le moment où les marchés
ont le mieux réagi à l'une de nos
annonceson évidemment quand vous faites
des annonces quand vous suivez vous
préparez le budget vous regardez de très
près la manière dont les investisseurs
bon le le moment le plus positif c'est
pas l'annonce de 5 % de déficit en 2025
alors que c'est un vrai choix difficile
qui veut dire que pour la première fois
la France va faire son plus gros effort
au début de la trajectoire et pas à la
fin de la trajectoire
c'est pas trop quand on détaille les
économies c'est quand on annonce les
impôts parce que les marchés et les
investisseurs considèrent à juste titre
d'ailleurs vu le niveau de prélèvement
obligatoire en France que le
consentement à l'impôt en France est un
des plus élevés dans le monde et si on
creuse le problème le gros problème ou
le très gros problème arrive quand le
consentement à l'impôt en France est
atteint toucher
euh je pense que les gilets jaunes parmi
les multiples explications ont été un
moment de ce
type je pense que ça peut arriver à
nouveau euh si on ch pas logiciel le le
l'atteinte du consentement à l'impôt les
gens ont marre de se faire cravacher
pour avoir des infirmières à 1500 €
attendre 24 heures sur un brancart dans
les hôpitaux avoir des trous sur les
routes avoir une défense où on est
obligé de sirer les les pneus des vabes
au 14 juillet des comme ça c'est-à-dire
exactement c'est-à-dire que enfin si je
le dis avec mes mots mais c'està-dire
que votre couple niveau de contribution
nationale satisfaction dans le service
public ne peut pas être trop longtemps
trop déséquilibré vous pouvez pas vous
avez quand même conscience que vous
savez on est en train de dire on l'a
fait et c'est très bien par ailleurs
d'expliquer à quoi servent les impôts
mais il faut faire attention dans ces
démarch là d'infantilisation je pense
que iser quelque chose pardon qui
infantilise quoi non mais quand on dit
on va expliquer à la terre entière les
impôts et cetera bon globalement je je
pense que tout le me enfin la plupart
des Français qui s'intéressent à ce
sujet là qui souhaitent s'intéresser les
chefs d'entreprise et chefs d'entreprise
notamment pas que comprennent
globalement quels sont les impôts et de
quel niveau ils sont pour les payer ils
sont assez bien au courant et quels sont
les services publics puisquon en est
tous les usagers pr
exemple 20 % de TVA en dedans
cotisation charge sociale appelez ça
comme vous voulez combien c'est 42 % les
cotisations oui
euh les pour pour moi on a pour moi on a
non pour moi on a 41 % 41 impôt sur les
sociétés 43
oui alors 41 % c'est tous les
prélèvements obligatoires donc
cotisation impô donc impô sur les
sociétés imp F imp sur les sociétés pour
ceux qui connaissent pas vous arrivez à
la fin de l'année vous avez fait un peu
de trésorerie pour anticiper les coups
durs et là il y a l'état qui arrive et
qui fait toc toc toc combien ils
prennent bah ça dépend mais bon
maintenant c'est 25 % toc toc toc 25 %
parce que tu as bien travaillé tu as
fait de la tro je te prends 25 % ensuite
impôt sur les dividendes
combien ce que le prélèvement
forfaitaire unique 33 enfin 30 pardon ça
fait combien tout ça additionner alors
c'est un bon calcul que je sais pas vous
faire
deem moi je vous donne l'ordre de grand
ENF ce que des boîtes qui sont taxées du
MO quand vous êtes chef d'entreprise que
vous êtes votre
patron vous rentrez 10 il vous reste
combien à la fin de l'année de voilà
c'est ce que j'allais dire l'ORD de
grandeur c'est entre de et 4 moi je moi
je dirais trois mais c'est ça TR autre
ordre de grandeur autre ordre de
grandeur
important qu' avait donné le patron de
Michelin à l'Assemblée nationale quand
ça quand ça coûte 120 ou quand quand
l'employeur met 120 sur la table il y a
à la fin 80 à 75 pour le salarié là où
en Allemagne c'est 100
B en fait une autre manière de le dire
et là c'est pas de l'fantilisation parce
que tout le monde est au courant je
pense mais c'est à nous de le faire
vivre dans enfin c'est à moi et à
d'autres de le faire vivre dans le débat
public c'est que c'est un jeu à somme
nul en l'occurrence entre votre salaire
et le prix de la consultation chez le
médecin le prix du taxi sanitaire et la
manière dont se passe le service public
et donc vous pouvez renoncer à une
partie de votre salaire pour un service
public collectivisé le problème c'est
que quand vous payez vous-même quand
vous êtes aux États-Unis vous avez un
salaire beaucoup plus élevé avec toutes
les inégalités que ça comporte et que
vous payez vous-même l'hôpital vous
savez exactement combien vous payez pour
exactement quel service mais quand on
est en France et que vous confiez votre
salaire à l'état pour qu'il s'occupe de
la santé c'est plus vous qui contrôlez
le service et c'est ça qui exaspère
aujourd'hui c'est que ce que pose la
question ce que les gens posent comme
question extrêmement juste c'est que
diable font-il de mon argent pour que
j'ai un si mauvais service et il y a pas
de réponse facile il y a des domaines où
vu les équipement et le coût des
équipements vu le besoin d'avoir une
main d'œuvre qualifié ça coûte très cher
et donc il y a pas de solution miracle
on va pas trouver demain la solution où
on baisse les impôts et où on augmente
la qualité de service à l'hôpital mais
il y a des domaines la fonction publique
territoriale euh le nombre d'agents
administratifs qui sont pas sur le
terrain euh le temps de travail dans la
fonction publ qui doivent être regardés
et c'est devenu des tabous je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez en 2017 campagne
présidentielle c'était la foire au
nombre de fonctionnaires supprimés alors
100000 200000 500000 c'est pas c'est pas
sûr que ce soit la meilleure manière
c'est pas supprimé c'est pas renouvelé
c'est ça poste poste supprimé donc pas
renouvelé bien sûr ah oui pardon on ne
licencie jamais personne sèchement sauf
cas très particulier donc on sait du non
remplacement ça ça a été balayé par le
covid on le comprend service public
service sensel ce qui fait que
maintenant on est en train de Voyer la
brèche s'est refermée et le tabou le
couvercle du tabou s'est posé on a plus
le droit d'en parler mais je je vous
jure je vous donner un exemple que je
devrais pas donner parce que c'est pas
dans mon intérêt mais peu importe j'ai
fait hier une matinale sur Public Sénat
ù j'ai parlé du besoin de réduire les
dépenses publiques et la présentatrice
m'a dit enfin l'interviewuse m'a dit
est-ce que ça inclut par exemple le
temps de travail de la fonction publique
et y compris potentiellement des
enseignants j'ai dit oui je crois que ça
mérite d'être regardé parce que les
enseignants sont mal payés qu'on a
besoin de mieux les payer et que comme
on pourra pas faire une augmentation
généraliser demain de 15 ou de 30 % des
salaires des enseignants il faut trouver
des solutions qui peuvent passer par
plus de travail je vous dis la vérité
j'ai reçu beaucoup de mails et j'ai
beaucoup de de de de de de messages sur
les réseaux sociaux et notamment sur
Twitter d'enseignants qui me disent vous
crachez sur le métier c'est horrible ce
que vous faites je n'ai jamais eu un mot
désagréable et j'adore les enseignants
j'ai la moitié de ma famille qui est
prof ça ne me viendrait pas à l'idée de
les critiquer chimie mes
grands-parents donc ça veut dire que
c'est devenu tabou ça veut dire qu' ne
parlons plus de rien dans aucun des
domaines et je peux vous dire que si
j'avais parlé des jardiniers paysagistes
employés territoriauxx dans les mairies
ça aurait été pareil le tabou c'est la
mort qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme tabou en
France pour vous le
pire alors si je reste si je reste dans
l'éc enfin si je reste dans les
politiques économiques et si je reste
dans le truc qui vous met la rage on va
se parler de français à français de
savoyard à bourguignon hein
et on se dit les choses maintenant bon
il y a un truc qui m'a beaucoup énervé
mais je trouve que c'est en train de
passer c'était la phobie du drapeau la
phobie de la France la phobie
du qu'est-ce que c'est que ce facho qui
a un drapeau français ou qu'est-ce que
c'est pourquoi il se dit qu'il vous
savez il y a un terme qui était tabou
longtemps ENF je pense que vous êtes
d'accord avec moi c'est le terme de
patriote pas pour rien qu'il a été la
différence entre patriote et
nationaliste ah c'est un c'est un beau
thème ça c'est un beau thème qui s'est
bien illustré à la fin du 19e c'est
que Ben la différence c'est que le
nationaliste comme par hasard il aime
bien quand des puissances étrangères
critiquent la France ou interviennent en
France ça le dérange pas parce que c'est
ses amis idéologiques et le patriote il
se bat
contre le patriote il est ouvert il est
pas il perd pas son micro
euh c'est pour ça qu'on a mis deux
micros av des problèmes neuromoteurs
vous voyez
pour l'ingénieur du son est en train de
crier fam avec ses ses typant non ça va
est-ce que vous voulez que je le remette
quand même vous pouvez le remettre il
est passé sur le second c'est très bien
donc donc le patriote est ouvert le
patriote il défend son pays
pragmatiquement et si ça et et et quand
il voit que on est dans un continent et
qu'il faut pas être seul il a pas de
problème à s'entendre avec l'allemand ou
l'espagnol le nationaliste il dit
surtout pas l'Allemagne et vous savez
quoi s'il faut s'allier s s'il faut
refuser l'alliance avec l'Allemagne mais
que ça nous affaiblit c'est pas grave
pour le plaisir je vais refuser
l'alliance comme ça je serai tout seul
il faut dire que les allemand ils nous
ont un peu chié dans les bottes quand
même sur le nucléire quand très
récemment le nucléaire c'est un scandale
mais
euh oui je ils nous ont pas aidé ils ont
été dur ils ont porté leurs intérêts
c'est une évidence moi je passe
régulièrement du temps en
Allemagne les milieux économiques
allemands disent les Français ils nous
ont quand même pas beaucoup aidé hein
euh le coût du [__] travail le le les
retraites ils ont affaibli la
convergence économique de l'Union
européenne
donc la force c'est la c'est la force
c'est le le croisement des points de vue
et évidemment qu'il faudrait les deux il
faudrait que nous on travaille davantage
et que ils soient un peu plus
intelligents industriellement je crois
qu'on travaille plus queux on gagne
moins alors il y a plusieurs choses oui
ça va ensemblef si on travaille moins et
qu'on a pas des PIBS si différents par
habitant même si tendance à s'écarter
c'est que notre productivité est
meilleure il y a le travail tout au long
de l'année et il y a le travail tout au
long de la vie euh les Allemands ils
sont affaiblis par le fait que la taux
de participation au marché du travail
des femmes est inférieure parce qu'ils
ont une culture qui fait que les femmes
allemandes on moins travailler
mais les Allemands sont en train de
passer à 67 ans les Italiens regardent
pour passer à 70 ans au fur et à mesure
et les Espagnols socio-démocrates je
parle pas d'un pays liberté tarien ou
ultra libéral économiquement que sais-je
parce qu'il faut affubler les gens de
caricature tu es en train de passer
aussi à 67 ans donc sur le travail tout
au long de la vie c'est un sujet donc il
y a le tabou du drapeau français si je
parle du Réard mais il y a un autre
tabou qui me gonfle beaucoup c'est
l'argent
euh moi je parce que vous en avez
peut-être votre patrimoine il est stocké
dans quoi vous votre déclaration du
patrimoine c'est combien alors je je ma
dé je crois que ma déclaration de
patrimoine doit être publique ou quasi
public donc je c'est une information
simple mon patrimoine est
négatif vous avez un un crédit j'ai j'ai
un crédit automobile que je suis en
train de finir de rembourser c'est quoi
comme voiture euh Citroën c'est une
citroë c'est bien c'est une Citroën C3
immatriculé dans le 92 non immatriculé
de savoir ça va
alors
et je ne perdrai pas le fil le l'autre
truc qui me gonfle l'argent pourquoi
parce que vous en avez pas tellement
parce que moi je suis ENF vous êtes
propriétaire de votre appartement non je
vous êtes locataire oui j'ai aucun
fanatisme de l'argent c'est-à-dire que
mes études ma formation mes centres
d'intérêt ne ne font pas que je pense à
gagner énormément d'argent que c'est
quelque chose qui me préoccupe qui mais
de fait dans le monde dans lequel onvit
c'est un facteur de réussite parmi
d'autres sauf qu'en France il est marqué
comme un tabou c'est-à-dire que ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut refire l'alpha et
l'oméga pas du tout on n'est pas
américain on le sera pas mais il est
marqué comme un tabou et ça a un impact
direct sur la manière dont les chefs
d'entreprise arrivent à se déployer dont
on les regarde de travers quand ils
réussissent un peu trop et cetera et
cetera et je pense que c'est c'est ça ça
peut paraître anodin mais je pense que
c'est un des ferment de nos
réticences c'est mon côté macronien
c'estd en même temps non c'est-à-dire
euh favoriser la réussite économique et
pas avoir peur que ça arrive l'évasion
fiscale c'est combien c'est comment
c'est par où c'est par
qui vaste question euh alors on va
commencer simplement c'est combien
alors moi j'ai été confronté à par les
services de Bercy et par des
personnalités extérieures à des chiffres
très différents
si je je vais commencer par la facilité
et inclure
optimisation zone grise don optimisation
c'est c'est légal mais c'est pas ce
qu'on souhaite c'est pas ce que l'esprit
du législateur a souhaité zone grise on
n'est pas tout à fait sûr que ce soit
légal et puis évasion c'est carrément
illégal et c'est de la fraude
caractérisée quand vous cumulez ça vous
passez d'un ordre de grandeur de 10 à 15
milliards à un ordre de grandeur 60 à
100 milliards en gros et les et
certaines ONG disent 200 300
milliards en incluant il me semble que
Oxfam l'a fait il me semble
que
aidez-moi la plus connue qu'on connaît
tous non je pensais pardon
attaque l'a fait aussi
bon quand vous êtes alors moi j'ai pas
été assez longtemps pour investiguer ce
sujet qui é d'ailleurs plutôt chez
Laurent saint-artin mais quand vous êtes
ministre et que vous appréhendez sujet
en fait vous allez l'appréhender avec
vos outils vos outils c'est tracf qui
est la cellule qui lutte contre le
blanchimement contre la fraude fiscale
caractérisée c'est la DN red la
direction nationale du renseignement
douanier et fiscal donc c'est ces outils
là c'est une des lois fiscales qui
avaient été passé pour avoir des agents
des sortes de James Bond du
renseignement fiscal qui pouvaient aller
investiguer dans les pays euh la clé de
de mon de de la conviction que je me
suis faite c'est la coopération
internationale c'est-à-dire que bien sûr
que vous pouvez avoir des supers agents
que vous pouvez avoir des système hyper
déployé mais enfin quand vous êtes avez
un microopays dans un continent très
lointain soit vous l'avez encerclé pris
en éo par de la coopération avec les
États-Unis l'OCDE les pays alentoursqu
je donne pas de pays mais si si c'est
intéressant oh mais vous oh vous voyez
de Luxembourg la Suisse alors
ça c'est c'est encore c'est encore une
mais je prends quand même une second je
mets les pieds dans le plat je prends
une seconde l'exemple du
Luxembourg il y a des pratiques légales
ou conforme au droit européens ou ou
quasi conforme au droit européen que la
France ne s'autorise pas
ou peu et que d'autres pays comme le
Luxembourg s'autorise et parmi celle-ci
parmi ceci et a le fameux rcrit fiscal
le rescrit fiscal bon la communauté à
mon avis est totalement informée mais je
le redis au cas où le riscr fiscal c'est
un deal une transaction entre un
particulier un contribuable une
entreprise et et un état et des agents
et là il y a une discrétion une marge de
manœuvre que vous pouvez avoir c'estàd
que vous pouvez dire bah écoutez vous
vous installez chez nous vous vous êtes
installé chez nous Vous menacez de
partir si on vous colle un contrôle
fiscal bah restez et on on passe
l'éponge et là c'est tout l'équilibre à
avoir entre rigidité de
l'application fermeté et puis
compétition fiscale avec les autres
États et le Luxembourg l'utilise pour
être poli et diplomate et comme un
ancien ministre toilette de manière
abondante il faut peut-être arrêter un
jour d'être poli et
diplomate question Internet
euh pardon
ou demande-lui pourquoi les dirigeants
français sent tê à rester dans le marché
européen de l'électricité alors que les
pays le alors que le pays est capable de
fournir une électricité pas chère à ses
entreprise qu'est-ce que la France a y a
gagné c'est une excellente question et
je m'excuse par avance parce que je vais
sûrement y répondre de manière
incomplète et j'assume de d'y répondre
avec euh mes éléments de compréhension
qui méritent d'être challengé bon il n'y
a pas de marché européen de
l'électricité c'est un terme générique
qu'on utilise pour dire qu'il y a des
règlements et des directives qui
facilitent euh la connexion et c'est
tout le c'est tout le défi immense du de
l'électricité la connexion si j'ose dire
entre deux types de flux de nature
radicalement différentes les flux enfin
le flux énergétique et donc le courant
électrique et l'argent qui sont très
différents bon et qu'il faut qu'on a
besoin d'ajustement en permanence ce que
fait RTE au niveau national et ce que
malheureusement ne fait pas le RTE
européen qui n'a pas la même enfin qui
n'existe pas qui n'a pas la même force
de frappe le marché européen tel qu'il
est nous a permis de faire deux choses
très très utiles pendant la crise
d'avoir de l'électricité quand on
manquait parce que nos centrales
nucléaires étaient à l'arrêt et
deuxièmement et là c'est aujourd'hui ce
soir j'ai pas le il faut aller sur
ellectricity Maps pour le savoir mais je
pense que alors là on est qu'est-ce
qu'on est on est un soir
d'hiver discours de Macron j'ai perdu la
notion du Président j'ai perdu la j'ai
perdu la notion du temps quand je me
suis installé dans cette pièce mais
j'imagine que on est à une heure où les
gens consomme encore de
l'électricité il est assez probable que
on exporte pas mal d'électricité vers
l'Allemagne pas fou et et c'est très
bien
et puis oua j'arrive pas à voir c'est
trop long l'écran 2,66 GW vers
l'Allemagne voilà donc ça fait quand
même pas mal d'argent ça fait combien de
centrale nucléaire alors on on c'est on
on là c'est du c'est en puissance un 2,6
GW donc 2,6 GW vous voyez c'est en gros
TR de trois tranches de TR trois petites
tranches de groses tranches euh mais sur
un parc de 56 he mais donc réacteur tout
réacteur pardon tout ça pour dire que
évidemment que c'est utile d'échanger et
qu'on est très content de pouvoir vendre
à nos voisins ça c'est une chose extrême
importante à l'inverse euh et on a des
prix qui doivent être plutôt bas par
rapport aux autres pays européens à
l'inverse la question légitime que tout
le monde se pose c'est qu'est-ce qui
fait que nos prix de l'électricité sont
encore aussi élevés il y a deux réponses
à ça d'abord il y a de
l'inerie c'est-à-dire que il y a encore
beaucoup de gens qui ont les contrats d'
a un an ou d' a 2 ans ou d' a 3 ans et
donc c'est pas le prix de ce soir de
production qui s'applique à ce qui paye
et puis il y a un deuxième élément c'est
que il faut l'assumer le prix du le coût
de production du nucléaire existant
n'est pas le même qu'aux US parce qu'on
a de la sûreté parce qu'on a aussi de la
bureaucratie qui est pas forcément utile
et je mets les pieds dans le plat parce
qu'on a des taxes
importantes et qu'on a une fiscalité
environnement qui est pas incitative à
l'électricité qui fait que la demande
est en déprimée et je finis juste
là-dessus il y a un pays qui est sorti
du marché européen qui a voulu sortir
marché européen le Portugal la
Grande-Bretagne la Grande-Bretagne qui
au moment du
brexit mécaniquement est sorti ils ont
fait des pieds et des mains pour y
rentrer et ils ont signé tous les
accords dérogatoires qui leur permettent
de rester je trouve que à défaut de
rentrer dans la technicité du truc c'est
un bon exemple je pense que le UK qui
fait un brexit c'est quand même assez
clair qu'ils avaient vraiment intention
de s'en barrer et aucun intérêt de
rester et que si c'était avantageux d'en
sortir ils en sortaient direct et
totalement et ils sont revenus
directement la queue entre les jambes la
queue entre les jambes ce que le
Portugal et Espagne ont fait ils ont pas
sorti ils ont juste redistribué ils ont
bloqué les prix et ils ont redistribué
plutôt aux entreprises nous on a
redistribué au
particuliers question deux questions
Internet où est-ce qu'il a mis son
argent or Bitcoin dollar action pierre
précieuson bon ben du coup je suis
désolé j'ai déçu en en dévoilant mon
patrimoine et donc je l'ai mis dans une
Citroën C3 C3 ouais ouais et vous aviez
pas l'opportunité d'en acheter une de
cases dans le stock du
ministère dieu merci un personne ne me
l'a proposé et de j ai même pas pensé
non votre C3 elle peut aller dans les
zones à particules pas particules comme
on les ZFE les Z à faible émission B en
plus j'habite à NC où une zone à faible
émission a été mise en place donc elle a
le critère pour rentrer c'est une
critère 1 c'est une critère 1 si je dis
pas de bêtises oui c'est critère
1 et elle
rentre c'est la difficulté du moment
c'està-dire que c'est combien de
personnes qui vont être laisé avec des
voitures qui ne valent plus rien c'est
combien de millions d'habitants combien
de millions de voitures c'est une des
premières missions que j'ai mené quand
j'étais agent à si sur la Prim
conversion les zones à faible émission
euh là j'ai pas le le le chiffre exact
d'autant plus que les zones à faible
émission sont devenu plus ou moins
facultativ et ont été décalé dans le
temps dans l'application de celle qui
compte euh voilà le doute que j'ai
aujourd'hui c'est que j'ai l'impression
qu'on est arrivé à des délais tels sur
les zones à faible émission que ça
correspond juste au renouvellement du
parc
automobile moi je suis pas bien sûr de
ce que vous êtes sûr de votre coup là
parce que là là là il y a par exemple
infermière qui fait qui travaille en
zone rurale qui est obligé de prendre le
Non Non mais il y a deux choses
différentes à quelle vitesse ça rentre
en application quels sont les critaires
les vignettes concernées et moi ce que
j'ai compris en tout cas je l'ai vu chez
moianci et c'est pareil dans certains
autres coins c'est qu'on décale les coup
près parce qu'en fait on n'est pas
capable d'assurer assez vite le
renouvellement et donc finalement on se
cale sur le renouvellement du parc
automobile et on s'approche de quelque
chose qui ressemble à
euh un peu de
marketing vous avez commencé avec quoi
comme
voiture euh j'ai commencé la voiture de
maman une voiture d' casase j'ai
commencé avec une vieille poubelle j'ai
oui j'ai commencé avec une Fiat Punto
d'occasion filé par un copain quien
servait plus et ensuite j'ai eu en
leasing
une 200
208 208 est-ce que vous comprenez que le
jeune étudiant qui a déjà du des
problèmes pour
s'alimenter quand il va acheter sa
voiture d'occase et qu'il se retrouve
plus pouvoir aller dans sa fac dans son
école ou dans son
alternance ça crispe un peu les gens al
c'est pour ça que alors un moi je suis
convaincu que les zones à faible
émission ne peuvent pas aller contre
alors vous mentionnez exemple des tuturs
moi je vous mentionne un autre exemple
que j'ai beaucoup vu quand j'ai
travaillé sur le sujet c'est qui a des
diesel vraiment polluant dans les pires
catégories c'est l'artisan et lui
l'artisan tout seul dans sa boîte il a
pas vraiment les moyens de mettre des
sommes colossales ou pire n'a pas la
possibilité parce qu'il n'existe pas le
véhicule électrique aujourd'hui qui
fonctionne et qui lui faut et ça c'est
le pire parce qu'en fait on crée la
vraie écologie ségrégative ou je sais
pas comment il faut l'appeler et les
gens vous posent légitimement la
question expliquez-moi pourquoi en 2022
2 ou 23 on était au pic de production de
consommation de charbon dans le monde et
le problème c'est mon véhicule essence
dans la banlieu d'an vous regardez à
Marseille les cheminées des pqueobo
oui question internet croyez-vous que le
consentement à l'impôt va durer
longtemps lorsque nous vous nous
promettez du sang et des larmes pour
relancer votre capitalisme à l'agonie
je je j'essaie de de de faire preuve de
bonne foi sur la
question bon moi je fais partie de ceux
qui qui réfutent la partie votre
capitalisme je pense que c'est notre
capitalisme à tous qu'on peut être
contre le
modèle mais et ça je l'ai entendu
l'autre jour sur un plateau de
télévision où je débattais avec le
président de la commission des finances
LFI Éric coqurel et où Olivier
beosanenau connait bien m'a dit que les
déficits étaient une invention des
capitalistes pour spéculer davantage sur
les classes populaires et leur expropri
et les exproprier davantage bon pour moi
il y a une réalité arithmétique qui est
celle que je décrivais tout à l'heure
c'est pas le capitalisme qui fait la
dépense publique au contraire c'est la
dépense publique c'est l'expression la
plus socialiste de la France donc je je
je si j'allais au bout du raisonnement
et que j'étais volontairement un peu
provoquant je dirais que c'est le manque
de capitalisme français qui crée le
déficit question internet monsieur
Armand les pauvres s'enfoncent dans la
précarité entre les loyers qui flambent
et les salaires qui stagnent quel
conseil tangible avez-vous pour eux je
rajouteraiis le prix de la bouffe qui
augmente aussi taqu
oui et et pardon je fais une parenthèse
méthodo mais qui est importante j'avais
l'ancest tral quand j'étais à
bercénergie qui a mone ta on a un
problème de mesure des prix c'estàdire
dire que quand vous allez expliquer aux
gens c'est ce qu'a fait mon prédécesseur
et cétait plus facile et moi j'ai essayé
de le faire on n pas eu le temps de
changer l'indicateur que aujourd'hui les
prix n'augmentent plus ou n'augmentent
plus que de 1,3 % et que eux en fait
leur paniier il augmentent de 10 % dans
la réalité parce que leur panier c'est
tagliatel coquillette sauce pomm de
terre et
Machin il y a une déconnexion
supplémentaire
donc en fait ce qui est dit ici les
exemp qui sont donnés c'est pas un
hasard je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui
qui maîtrise son truc c'est que les
inégalités en France n'augmentent pas
beaucoup ce qu'on appelle le coefficient
de Genis qui permet de mesurer
n'augmente pas beaucoup on préserve ça
il y a beaucoup de redistribution ce qui
a beaucoup changé dans la composition du
revenu des gens c'est les dépenses dites
contraintes logement transport
alimentation qui absorbe quasiment
chauffage échauffage bien sûr c'est ce
que je mets dans J ça absorbe la quasi
totalité de leur dépenses et c'est ça
qui fait que les gens
oui se trouve à payer voir parfois
emprunter pour payer des dépenses
courantes et là à mon avis si je prends
seconde de recul la solution n'est pas
que dans l'augmentation des salaires qui
de toute façon ne peuvent pas suivre un
rythme démesuré vu la productivité et la
compétition internationale mais elle est
typiquement dans le logement pour moi le
logement c'est un échec des dernières
années net on l'a pas considéré comme un
secteur économique la production a
ralenti ça a eu des conséquences
directes sur le logement des plus
pauvres
le Conseil tangible mais c'est je sais
pas si c'est fait exprès pour me pousser
à moi qui a pas de problème d'argent à
donner un conseil tangible au pauvres ce
serait très très mal venu le conseil que
je nous donne à nous c'est de nous
réveiller sur la politique du logement
on a commencé à le faire avec un certain
nombre de mécanismes fiscaux mais il
faut aller plus loin je je vous donne un
exemple moi je suis dans un territoire
frontalier avec la Suisse donc ça coûte
très cher de se loger et les gens qui
ont les moyens peuvent se loger mais les
autres qui travaillent en France on une
difficulté Inui à se loger moi ce que je
propose c'est qu' on est un peu des
opérations commando vous prenez le
Conseil départemental les bailleurs
sociaux quelques employeurs il créent un
fond public privé et ensemble ils
financent sans logement pour les
infirmières du change le centre
hospitalier d'Ancy pour les gens qui
travaillent dans les supermarchés
anéiens il y a combien de malall logés
en
France alors ça le mallogement alors je
vais pas vous donner un chiffre absurde
mais pour mon mon souvenir en ordre de
grandeur c'est quasiment 10 % de la
population donc s'il y a 50 30 je sais
pas combien a de foyés 45 millions Foy
en France ENF c'est entre
entre 3 et 5 millions plus de 4 millions
si mes souvenirs sont bons et après vous
avez les donc ça c'est le mal logement
c'est l'inadéquation du logement euh aux
personnes dans le foyer puis vous avez
les personnes à la rue et là c'est des
dizaines des centaines de milliers de
personnes 300000 c'est combien de
mineurs
forcément un/ers au
moins 350000 personnes étaient sans
domicile en France la source c'est
quoi c'est BFM TV bon et le seuil de
pauvreté en France c'est combien alors
ça c'est pareil c'est un vrai problème
parce que le seuil de pauvreté il est
défini par l'INC enfin la DARES mais euh
Inc ou ou
DARES service statistique àar
statistique de l'État c'est 60 % du
salaire
médian donc en fait c'est un
pourcentage d'une
médiane autant dire donc le seuil de
pauvreté en France il doit être à 800 ou
900 € puisque c'est le le puisque le
médian maintenant doit être considéré en
revenu disponible à 1200 donc c'est
entre ça dépend comment il est calculé
mais c'est entre 800 et 1000 bon donc
c'est combien le salaire médian en
France en 2022 alors le salaire médien
ça dépend brut net renu disponible mais
en général on parle de 1200
€. et le salaire moyen il est supérieur
j'ai pas compris combien le salaire
médian B ça dépend net brut revenu
disponible mais en général quand on
parle en revenu disponible on parle de
1200 €. et donc le le seuil de pauvreté
c'est combien en FR et donc le seuil de
pauvreté le enfin ce qu'on appelle le
seuil de pauvreté c'est 60 % de ça donc
ça fait combien bah 12 x 6 72 donc 7 à 8
100 € vous êtes sûr de votre cût bah
enfin je vous donne le je vous donne le
je vous donne la définition du seuil de
pauvreté le SMIC il est combien en
France alors le SMIC brut il est à à peu
près 1600 €
maintenant vous être planté sur le seuil
de pauvreté je pense non je vous dis
rien bah si c'est bah ça dépense que euh
question internet si tous les pays du
monde sont endettés où est
l'argent je suis pas sûr de comprendre
la question je la répète question de
voras si tous les pays du monde sont
endettés virgule où est l'argent
euh mais c'est les États qui sont
endettés c'est-à-dire que c'est la
puissance publique enfin l'État qui est
endetté et la dette elle elle est
detenue partout dans le monde y compris
en France je je vous donne un exemple
pour être peut-être plus
clair la dette japonaise elle est très
très importante plus importante que chez
nous je crois que c'est presque 200 %
enfin c'est c'est colossal mais elle est
détenue quasi intégralement par des
japonais c'est en train de changer là ça
évolue parce pour plein de raisons je je
m'étends pas démographique démographique
en
France beaucoup plus varié c'est que la
laisse de la dette française elle est
détenue chez qui j'ai aux États-Unis au
la laisse de la dette française
est détenue par le Qatar elle est
détenue par l'Arabie Saoudite par la
Chine par les États-Unis par qui en
général notre dette oui heureusement on
le sait et l'Agence France Trésor donne
des des proportions plus précises que ce
que je vais vous dire ici l'ordre de
grandeur c'est qu'il y a un/4 de non
européens enfin extra non français non
européens acteur institutionnel non
français non européen question internet
certains médias vous ont qualifié
d'arriviste et de pentin de la macronie
suggérant un manque de conviction
personnelle comment répondez-vous à ces
critiques concernant votre engagement
politique et votre indécence votre
indépendance
d'esprit mon boulot c'est de le montrer
hein que j'ai des convictions et que je
suis indépendant d'esprit
eu j'ai bien senti que quand j'ai été
nommé parce que j'étais jeune enfin
j'espère que je le suis encore un peu
parce
que parce que les gens sont très
critique de l'exmajorité présidentielle
et du
Président on fait un un malgame ben le
peuple n'a jamais tort enfin sinon on
n'est pas en
démocratie je vais pas vous faire vous
trouvez vous trouvez que la démocratie
française et européenne est
respecté mais par les par les dirigeants
en fait ENF c'est c'est un débat
tellement
compliqué dieu merci la démocratie est
respectée c'est-à-dire que il y a des
élections les personnes qui arrivent qui
gagnent l'élection présidentielle
devienne président de la République
quand un parti a pas la majorité absolue
il fait pas de gouvernement seul et
cetera et cetera et ensuite la question
derrière c'est est-ce que l'esprit de la
démocratie est suffisamment respecté par
tout le monde il y a tellement à dire
démocratie sociale démocratie locale
démocratie nationale mais je pense que
la enfin pas vous refaire le coup de la
démocratie est le pire régime à
l'exception de tous les autres la
démocratie est porteur en
elle-même de son insatisfaction
c'està-dire que précisément quand on est
démocrate on l' jamais assez on aimerait
avoir une élection toutes les mois V
tous les mois une votation tous les mois
pour décider de tel ou tel sujet et ça
c'est l'équilibre entre efficacité et et
niveau de démocratie question à 15
milliards qui a saboté
nstream avec votre expérience de la
commission énergie et votre mandat de
ministre quel est votre
avis je j'ai pas d'avis sur le sujet je
je je n'ai pas de d'information que que
que le grand public n'a pas eu
et ça là le financement de la la dette à
tout variable c'est une bonne opération
euh si alors si on parle des emprunts
toxiques version collectivité locale qui
ont conduit à ce qu'on a connu non si on
parle d'un autre point qui est souvent
débattu et qui est important qui est des
obligations indexées sur l'inflation là
c'est différent parce que on a besoin
enfin ça en gros il y a des
investisseurs qui n'achètent que ça ou
qui ne sont intéressés que par ça et
donc c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure il y a le coût de la dette ça
c'est une chose et puis il y a l'appétit
de la dette et c'est important d'avoir
une vaste diversité de personnes qui
veulent acheter notre dette pour pouvoir
faire jouer la compétition et avoir une
dette qui est aussi possédée par des
gens qui sont prêtes à la prendre moins
cher parce que c'est des produits qui
les intéressent question Internet inarc
entre parenthèses donc payé pendant ses
études c'est vrai puis député entre
parenthèses 6000 € mensuels c'est vrai
ministre un temps entre parenthèses
10000 € mensuel comment peut-il avoir un
patrimoine négatif et vous voulez
expliquer qu'il faut faire des économies
quand vous gagnez 2000 € mensuel salaire
médian vous avez un château à entretenir
en location mais vous chauffez au
bois vous voyez on est vraiment en plein
dans le tabou que je vous disais tout à
l'heure visiblement cette personne a un
problème avec l'argent et et avec ce que
chacun on fait ENF je veux dire euh
c'est quand même fait quoi de votre
pognon vous allevez faire du son au
parachute à capmandou c'est quand même
incroyable de
devoir se justifier je peux vous
apporter euh ce que j'ai fait de mon
argent à qui je l'ai donné à qui j'ai
fait des cadeaux avec ma famille enfin
et et et là en fait on touche un point
qui est très intéressant dans la
démocratie et qui est très difficile à
expliquer c'est qu'est-ce qu'on veut euh
à quoi on veut que ressemblent les gens
qui nous représentent est-ce qu'on veut
que quelqu'un qui nous représente est
travaillé avant et fait fortune avant
c'est un gage de réussite
entrepreneuriale après tout j'aimerais
qu'elon mus soit président de la
République parce que lui il a réussi
quelque chose avant bon est-ce qu'on
veut que ce soit quelqu'un qui a
consacré sa vie au bien public ce
monsieur a oublié de dire que entre
lenat et et la députation j'ai été 4 ans
agent au ministère de l'Économie des
Finances j'ai gagné un salaire et j'ai
travaillé
bon ensuite est-ce qu'on veut des gens
dont on sa est-ce qu'on veut que les
élus disent exactement ce qu'ils font
tous les jours de l'argent qu'ils ont
gagné directement personnellement et
est-ce qu'on croit que si on impose ça
on va avoir plutôt plus de gens qualifié
compétent ou moins et dernier point euh
est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il préférait ce
monsieur que j'ai accumulé avec un
patrimoine avec un argent qu'il
considère comme public parce que la
question là ce serait vous avez vu il
s'est il s'est enrichi avec l'argent
public en fait soit on accepte que les
fonctionnaires soient payés par de
l'argent public et que les élus soient
payés par de l'argent
public soit non et dans ce cas-là on
considère que ça doit être fait
bénévolement mais là ça a d'autres
conséquences et comment vous avez pris
le fait que les sénateurs soient
augmentés de 700
balles je crois alors je connais moins
le Sénat mais je crois qu'ils ont
augmenté leur leurs avances pour frais
de mandat c'est-à-dire ce qui permet de
payer la permanence les prês énergétique
et cetera bon on a eu ce débat pendant
le budget sur la présidence de la
République l'Assemblée nationale le
Sénat c'est un débat de symbole au sens
où malheureusement on parle en millions
d'euros là où on parle en milliers de
milliards ailleurs mais vu la situation
on a pas de choix il faut être raccord
symboliquement avec ce qu'on fait et
donc il faut à mon sens pendant un bon
moment au moins arrêter vous pensez là
là sur les courbes d'audience on a vu
quand le président commença à par parler
et les gens sont désintéressés tout de
suite et et quand le match de foot a
commencé à votre avis le Président il va
nous annoncer quoi ce soir du moins il
l'a déjà annoncé mais nous on a pas eu
le temps de le
voir je sais pas s'il va faire une
annonce spéciale je pense que tout le
monde en en tout cas les gens auquels je
parle sont très inquiets
euh parce qu'on parlait de prévisibilité
et d'imprévisibilité donc si vous dites
à quelqu'un si vous expliquez aux gens
ce qui peut se passer euh dans les
prochains mois et comment on va faire
pour arriver au meilleur scénario en
gros ce qui peut se passer c'est une
trêve et une paix négocié au détriment
de la souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Ukraine ou une
poursuite des négociations qui qui amène
à ne pas faiblir et à récupérer de
l'aide américaine au moins vous donnez
des axes des branches un arbre de
probabilité aux gens et ça les rassure
et c'est aussi le rôle là je fais pas de
politique al je pense que c'est aussi le
rôle de du chef d'une nation de venir
poser l'éventail des possibilités la
société vous êtes fait vacciné contre le
covid oui combien de fois euh trois vous
avez des effets secondaires genre akouf
mal non
rien est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins
à nous conseiller
euh
alors je commence par la littérature si
c'est autorisé mais c'est pas que de la
littérature saintexupéri terre des
hommes comme dans pas mal de ces
bouquins il y a raconte ces expéditions
pour l'Aéropostale et en fait ce qui est
incroyable c'est très peu de technologie
et donc moins de technologie plus de
caractère donc Terre des Hommes euh un
que je suis en train de lire Soole d'Abi
parlons-nous la même
langue il y a des gens qui parlent de
tranquillité publique et d'autres que ça
insupporte qui disent non mais c'est de
la sécurité il y a les gens qui parlent
des territoires personne n'a jamais vu
vous savez je plus la phrase de de cooc
personne n'a jamais vu un territoire là
se déplacer bon c'est le fait d'utiliser
des mots qui font plus référence à des
choses concrètes et donc on s'y perd
c'est le magma et je pense que c'est
aussi un des problèmes qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans notre débat public Lang
oui la NV langue et le fait qu'on fait
qu'on fait que des mots font référence à
d'autres mots et plus à des choses donc
on construit des cathédrales
complètement infréquentable de de mots
euh et puis on n pas genre la la la
croissance négative la croissance
négative euh mais même des choses
responsable mais pas coupable oui mais
je vais vous donner des trucs qui sont
beaucoup plus ancrés la soutenabilité
euh ça peut vouloir dire 1000 choses euh
est-ce que ça veut dire une croissance
fondée sur les ressources matérielles
existantes est-ce que ça veut dire bref
et donc il faut utiliser des mots qui
font référence à les choses et énergie
je dans un dernier qui avec qui je
partage pas tout mais qui est quand même
sacrément bien documenté Jean-Baptiste
fressose sans transition euh fresn oui
fresn fr fr je sais plus pardon désolé
si j'écorche son nom moi le le le le le
le le le message en une phrase c'est il
n'y a pas eu de transition énergétique
on a juste additionné les énergie et
donc il va jusqu'à la caricature jusqu'à
l'huile de baleine en fait même même
l'huile de baleine on n' pas tant on n
pas tant transformé l'énergie par
l'huile de baleine en une autre on les a
additionné aujourd'hui on est quasiment
au pic de charbon dans le monde et dans
l'esprit de tout le monde on a déjà
transitionné du charbon à autre chose en
fait on ajoute beaucoup plus les
énergies d'où la question des ressources
qu'est-ce qui va se passer si on na pas
un saut technologique alors vous parlez
de l'huile de baleine du charbon
l'électricité du nucléaire qu'est- si on
n pas la
fusion facilement déployé à grande
échelle mondialement qu'est-ce qui va se
passer on va être dans la situation
enfin on est dans plus
exactement on on vivra ou on ouvrira les
yeux sur la situation qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire mais qu'on ne
n'a pas décidé d'acter c'est-à-dire la
finitude de la ressource et et la
finitude de ressource n'empêche à mon
avis pas tout à fait c'est là que je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec Jean
coviss une forme de croissance
économiqueévolution
secteur mais elle va poser comme tout
premier problème de la tension
géopolitique majeure le prix à payer
pour de la ressource va être énorme
est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations une bouteille à la
mer quelque chose
d'impérissable un conseil général comme
ça moi je je passe du temps dans les
lycées sur intervention et cetera et
parmi les les choses que je que je
répète le plus c'est liser des gens ou
écouter peu importe des gens avec
lesquels vous n'êtes pas du tout
d'accord je moi je passe du temps à le
faire avec ce qu'on appelle par
l'extrême gauche ou l'extrême droite peu
importe il faut lire des gens avec
lesquels on n'est pas du tout d'accord
parce que ça vient décaper tous vos
arguments faciles à la mort moileneux
que vous utilisez dans société sur
lesquels personne ne vous contredit
jamais parce que tout le monde est
d'accord avec vous et puis ça vous
permet vous d'aller choper
l'intelligence ailleurs et ça c'est
quand même la plus belle chose qui soit
je trouve Antoine Armand merci merci à
vous
[Musique]